norman werden wenn es zahlungen für
landwirte und landwirtinnen gibt wir
schauen auf das nächste thema das hier
im plenarsaal diskutiert wird da geht es
um den bundeswehreinsatz in mali von der
un es gibt zwei bundeswehreinsätze in
mali also zwei einsätze an denen die
bundeswehr beteiligt ist jetzt wird erst
einmal die blauhelm mission besprochen
die seit 2013 ja in mali zum schutz der
zivilbevölkerung ist die situation in
mali ist schwierig schon seit jahren
versuchen
konflikte versuchen islamistische
extremisten dort an die macht zu kommen
und
es gab allein seit august 20 20 zweimal
ein militärputsch es gibt ziemliche
konflikte zwischen den militär runter
und den westlichen ländern und nicht
zuletzt gab es berichte über ein
massaker an zivilisten in mora bundes
außenministerin annalena baerbock war
gerade in mali sie wird hier auch als
erstes sprechen in dieser debatte
wir schlafen nicht wir haben angst das
waren die worte die uns lieben
kolleginnen und kollegen mich und möchte
mich auf die reise nach mali begleitet
haben als allererstes gesagt haben als
wir zusammen saßen bei 45 grad im
schatten ingo wir unsere dort
stationierten soldatinnen und soldaten
im rahmen von - mal besucht haben wir
schlafen nicht wir haben angst weil wir
kaum sicher sind dass wir morgen noch
auf den markt gehen können wir schlafen
nicht wir haben angst weil unsere kinder
nicht mehr wirklich sicher zur schule
gehen können diese frauen diese männer
diese väter diese mütter fürchten sich
vor terroristischen schergen die in den
dörfern in der dortigen region angst und
schrecken verbreiten und wir haben
gemeinsam die menschen dort vor ort
gebraucht fragt was braucht ihr als
aller wichtigstes und die antwort kam
sofort sicherheit sicherheit sicherheit
und genau darum geht es bei diesem -
mandat und es geht auch um unsere eigene
sicherheit weil wir nicht wollen dass im
saal rückzugsräume für international
vernetzte terrororganisation
entstehen für organisierte kriminalität
denn wir wissen wenn sich - mann aus
mali zurückziehen würde dann würde das
vakuum noch mehr andere kräfte füllen
das gilt für islamistische kämpfer aber
es gilt eben auch für russische kräfte
die berichte die wir in den zeitungen
gelesen aber die wir natürlich auch vor
ort gehört haben über
menschenrechtsverletzungen durch
malischen und russische truppen sind
furchtbar und sie zeigen auch auf ganz
deutliche weise worum es für uns ja auch
geht nämlich uns diesen kräften
gemeinsam mit den menschen vor ort
entgegen zu stellen die nichts auf
menschenrechte geben nichts auf
demokratie und nichts auf eine
regelbasierte ordnung und auch deswegen
und davon bin ich zutiefst überzeugt
müssen wir hier engagiert bleiben gerade
jetzt in diesem moment wo russland
seinen grausamen krieg in der ukraine
führt bei ihr
weitergeht nichts sagen und ja das ist
eine politische entscheidung wir
konzentrieren uns noch auf das was für
unsere eigenen haustür passiert was
unglaublich wichtig ist sondern ganz im
gegenteil
genau in diesem moment nehmen wir weiter
unsere verantwortung in der welt war
gerade jetzt oder auch das ist die
botschaft die wir mit der unterstützung
dieses - mandates senden deutschland ist
der größte westliche truppen stelle
einmal wir bringen dort fähigkeiten ein
die andere beteiligte praktisch nicht
ersetzen können heron drohnen
transporthubschrauber wir sind in grau
an nationen für belgien estland irland
litauen luxemburg die niederlande die
schweiz das heißt die soldatinnen und
soldaten aus diesen ländern sind auch
auf unseren schutz und die unterstützung
der bundeswehr angewiesen
und deswegen entscheiden wir wenn wir
dieses mandat nicht zu bestimmen würden
dass wir uns eben auch aus dieser
verantwortung gegenüber den anderen
zurückziehen würden ich glaube dann
droht ein dominoeffekt der die mission
im ganzen schwer treffen würde und zwar
nicht nur für die westlichen truppen
stellen sondern das ist ja eine breite
un mission sondern dann auch für
truppensteller aus bangladesch sri lanka
niger oder dem senegal und wir sehen
auch wir sind dann weitergereist
gemeinsam in den niger das ist eben
effekte auch für das dortige land mit
einer
demokratischen regierung
es stimmt das möchte ich auch ganz offen
und deutlich sagen weil von schönrederei
halte ich nichts erst recht nicht den
mandaten die situation in magie ist
alles andere als einfach auch das haben
wir gemeinsam die wir kolleginnen und
kollegen die mit waren dort vor ort in
bamako erlebt ich habe deswegen dem
präsidenten im übergangspräsidenten
deutscher und dem außenminister die ob
auch dieser geputschten regierung sehr
sehr deutlich gemacht der übergang zu
einer gewählten regierung darf nicht
weiter verschleppt werden das fordern
wir nicht nur von europäischer seite
sondern
gemeinsam mit ecowas und auch der vn
sicherheitsrat aber ich möchte eben ganz
deutlich sagen diese minus x mission
sichert nicht die malische regierung ab
der einsatz unterstützt die malische
bevölkerung menschen die auf dem markt
gehen wollen kinder die endlich wieder
in der schule wollen und natürlich
wissen wir dass es für stabilität mehr
braucht als militär diese mission
alleine wird nicht alleine für
stabilität sorgen aber andersherum gilt
es eben auch ohne ein mindestmaß an
sicherheit ohne diesen mindestmaß an
militärischen schutz wird es eine
politische arbeit gerade auch von der
internationalen gemeinschaft dort kaum
weitergeben können dass sie sie eben
dann auch dass unser engagement dialog
prozess in den regional kommunen vor ort
gerade auch im medizinischen bereich im
klimaschutz bereich im
menschenrechtsbereich so nicht
weitergehen könnte daher betrachten wir
die lage so wie sie ist kompliziert
komplex aber wir stellen uns dieser
herausforderung
die verteidigungsministerien und ich
haben deswegen auch gegenüber dem
generalsekretär der vereinten nationen
und unseren bündnispartnern und
bündnispartnern deutlich gemacht dass
jetzt in dem moment die französischen
kollegin angekündigt haben ihre
unterstützungsleistung im herbst
wahrscheinlich zurückzufahren dass wir
bis dahin ersatz für die
kampfhubschrauber brauchen wir als
deutsche schlagen indem man davor als
deutsche bundesregierung dass wir
personell aufstocken von 1100 soldaten
auf 1400 und auch technisch vor allen
dingen den flughafenbetrieb weiter
unterstützen denn natürlich gilt die
verantwortung für sicherheit nicht nur
den menschen vor ort sondern auch
unseren soldatinnen und soldaten und
deswegen sagen wir auch sehr deutlich in
diesem mandatstext wenn der schutz für
deutsche soldatinnen und soldaten nicht
mehr ausreichend gewährleistet werden
könnte dann werden wir natürlich unseren
beitrag anpassen und wenn nötig auch
beenden ja diese mandats entscheidung
ist schwieriger als vor einem jahr ich
glaube aber sie ist auch wichtiger als
vor einem jahr wir möchten die deutliche
botschaft setzen deutschland zieht sich
in der welt nicht zurück trotz und
gerade wegen des krieges in der ukraine
bleiben wir international im rahmen der
vereinten nationen engagiert wir
überlassen die internationale ordnung
nicht denjenigen die keine
menschenrechtlichen und
völkerrechtlichen skrupel haben wir
zeigen flagge für die sicherheit der
menschen money und für unsere gemeinsame
internationale sicherheit herzlichen
dank ich bitte um unterstützung wie das
mandaten
annalena baerbock die bundes
außenministerin hat hierfür eine
verlängerung des bundeswehreinsatzes
geworben als parlamentsarmee darf die
bundeswehr nur ins ausland geschickt
werden wenn das parlament dem zugestimmt
ich möchte an dieser stelle sagen wir
freuen uns alle dass sie heil aus kiew
zurück sind sie haben einen guten besuch
gemacht es war zeit dass die
bundesregierung sich blicken lassen und
auch wir als opposition waren stolz auf
ihren auftritt in den letzten tagen in
kiel
ich kann ihnen trotzdem nicht ersparen
dass wir natürlich erhebliche probleme
haben mit dem was die bundesregierung
uns heute hier zur fortsetzung des - mal
der deutschen beteiligung an - war in
mali vorlegt also zunächst einmal hat es
das bisher noch nicht gegeben dass die
bundesregierung um 13 uhr 35 den
mitgliedern des deutschen bundestages
den mandatstext zuleitet der um 15 16
uhr 30 also knapp drei stunden später
hier beraten werden soll wenn sie
parlamentsbeteiligung wirklich ernst
nehmen dann müssen sie uns auch die
gelegenheit lassen und die gelegenheit
geben uns mit den mandatstext
auseinandersetzen bevor wir hier in
einer ersten lesung eintreten
und ich weiß dass der eine oder andere
kollege aus der regierungsposition jetzt
haben sich unter dem tisch beifall
geklatscht hat ich finde wir sollten
unbedingt dafür sorgen dass das so etwas
nicht wieder passiert sondern dass wir
was die fristen angeht uns doch
parlamentarischer verhalten
das kritische
was daraus was vielleicht darauf
hindeutet dass dadurch dass es so
verzögert worden ist ist das natürlich
auch das mandat mit heißer nadel
gestrickt dass wir wissen seit zwölf
monaten das am 31 die beiden mal die
mandate auslaufen wir wissen seit dem 17
februar dass die franzosen ihre
komponenten ihre wichtigen wesentlichen
komponenten die auch für unseren einsatz
entscheidend sind abziehen werden und
dennoch haben wir auch bestimmte
anforderungen an dieses mandat auf
moritz bisher auf die franzosen
verlassen konnten keine antworten der
vorrunde aus sie haben bisher in diesem
mandatstext und in der begründung keine
antwort gegeben es bleibt die frage
offen wie luft nach unterstützung für
deutsche soldaten und soldatinnen und
soldaten im einsatz und für unsere
partner in dauer bereitgestellt werden
kann die flugzeuge unserer partner in
der hauptstadt bamako sind zu weit weg
wir haben keine helikopter mehr vor ort
ich frage die bundesregierung was hat
sie unternommen um sicherzustellen dass
diese komponente ausgefüllt wird haben
sie vielleicht auch unkonventionelle
überlegungen angestellt dass so etwas
vielleicht auch drohnen bewaffnete
drohnen aus israel den man vielleicht
ließen könnte oder so übernehmen könnten
denn ich glaube ohne diese luft nach
unterstützung ist der einsatz deutlich
gefährlicher als es heute ist und das
bereitet uns große bauchschmerzen
ähnliche bauchschmerzen haben wir auch
ein blick auf die sogenannte rolle 2 in
der medizinischen versorgung wir haben
letztes jahr einen angriff auf deutsche
kräfte gehabt mit zahlreichen
verwundeten wir mussten uns auf andere
abstützen das hat dann zusammenarbeit
mit bis hinein in die chinesische
mission gegeben das ist auch etwas was
jetzt wenn die franzosen sich
zurückziehen nicht mehr der form
gewährleistet ist und auch da hätte man
genügend zeit gehabt in den letzten
monaten klare regelungen zu treffen dass
diese medizinische versorgung im notfall
auch in dieser rolle zwei
bereitgestelltes das ist das zweite das
dritte ist der flughafen muss operabel
bleiben in jeder hinsicht denn unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten sind darauf
angewiesen dass diese luftbrücke für
versorgungsgüter vielleicht auch im
notfall für den abtransport von
verwundeten steht und wenn das nicht
geleistet werden kann dann ist dieser
einsatz in seiner substanz gefährdet und
dann haben wir große bau spatzen den
zuzustimmen ich schlage ich sage dass
die bundesregierung ist in den letzten
monaten versäumt hat die nötigen
vorbereitungen zu treffen diese lücken
auszufüllen dahin war es allein auf die
un die verantwortlichkeit den lasse ich
nicht gelten denn was sind die vereinten
nationen die vereinten nationen sind ja
nur so stark wie die partner die sie
gemeinsam will und deutschland will und
ist ein spiel ein starker partner sein
und ist ein starker partner der un also
wir müssen im zweifel auf diesen schuh
anziehen hubschrauber haben wir ja bei
der bundeswehr ja vielleicht nicht mit
dem kampfhubschrauber aber für andere
zwecke also irgendwie eine lösung
zusammen zu bringen wird ja wohl
bitteschön möglich sein denn auch wir
glauben dass dieser einsatz richtig und
wichtig ist wir haben die richtige
begründung geliefert der begründung
schließe ich mich an ich möchte nicht
dass molly zum hort von terrorismus wird
ich möchte auch nicht dass sich
sicherheit in mali allein durch von
russland bezahlte söldner und der
missachtung von menschenrechten und
kriegsvölkerrecht wahrgenommen wird das
muss die vereinten nationen machen und
wenn die vereinten nationen sich nicht
auf deutschland verlassen kann auf wen
sollen sie sich denn sonst verlassenen
diesem sinne werden wir harte beratung
wird dieses mandat haben bevor wir
nächste woche dann die entscheidung
treffen ob es verlängert oder nicht als
oppositionsfraktion herzlichen dank
der sprecher für auswärtiges der unions
fraktion jürgen hardt war das hat hier
noch einmal betonte man müsse sich auf
deutschland doch verlassen schließlich
und auf ihn wird jetzt antworten
christine lambrecht
bundesverteidigungsminister kann
genau das sind die fragen mit denen wir
uns beschäftigen müssen dann wenn die
franzosen ab 10 beziehungsweise jetzt
schon vorher aber das sind die fragen
die beantwortet werden müssen und jetzt
kann man sagen das kann deutschland
alleine machen das kann deutschland
nicht alleine machen aber wir werden
unserer verantwortung bewusst
beispielsweise dadurch dass wir sehr
wohl sagen werden eine fähigkeit die
fehlen wird wenn frankreich ab sieht
nämlich die medizinische versorgung da
sehen wir uns in der lage das zu
gewährleisten
diesen rollte standard aufrecht zu
erhalten das ist ganz wichtig dass sich
die soldatinnen und soldaten darauf
verlassen können dass wenn es zu so
einer situation kommt dann die
bestmöglichste medizinische versorgung
gewährleistet ist das sehen wir und
deswegen haben wir auch die obergrenze
in bezug auf die möglichkeiten für
soldatinnen und soldaten angehoben weil
wir das mit gedacht haben und sie haben
genau den finger in die wunde gelegt wo
sehr problematisch werden wird denn das
ist ein mandat wo wirklich große große
erwartungen an uns gestellt werden an
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten die dort
eine hervorragende arbeit machen in
bezug auf die aufklärung mit strähnen
aber auch mit aufklärung vor ort durch
gespräche und dort in der lage dann sind
ein entsprechendes lagebild all
denjenigen zu camp zu geben die diesen
wichtigen kampf gegen extremisten gegen
terroristen führen und deswegen ist es
so wichtig dass wir auch alles versuchen
damit genau diese arbeit diese
hervorragende arbeit weitergeführt
werden können da kann ich aber nicht
sagen
das machen wir auch leben können das
muss einfach so weitergehen sondern ich
als verteidigungsministerin sehe mich da
sehr wohl in der verantwortung dafür zu
sorgen dass der bestmöglichste schutz
für unsere soldatinnen und soldaten dann
auch gewährleistet ist und wenn die
fraktion abzählen im sommer im herbst
dann wird es diese lücke geben denn
diese diese kampfhubschrauber sind
erforderlich dass diejenigen die
rausfahren die aufklären dass die sich
auch darauf verlassen können dass sie
bestmöglichst west möglichst geschützt
wird und dieser herausforderung
sie haben sowohl die außenminister als
auf ich mehrfach bei den vereinten
nationen vorgetragen mehrfach deutlich
gemacht dass wir sehr wohl bereit sind
diese aufgabe vorzuführen dass arbeit
diese lücke geschlossen werden muss und
da ist die vereinzelt sind die vereinten
nationen jetzt auch in der verantwortung
und da bestehen wir auch darauf deswegen
ist es auch so im mandat angelegt erst
wenn diese voraussetzungen erfüllt ist
dann können wir auch weiter bleiben und
genauso klar ist es angelegt zu dieser
schutz ist uns wichtig und ohne diesen
schutz können wir dort nicht weiter habe
genauso wie die dritte frage wie geht es
weiter mit dem flughafen in grau mit dem
brandschutz der damit verbunden ist auch
das ist eine aufgabe die zu beantworten
ist und da kann man nicht einfach immer
nur sagen ihr deutsche ihr seid
willkommen ihr deutsche leistet
hervorragende arbeit ja das ist so aber
wir müssen auch dafür sorgen dass
diejenigen die diese hervorragende
arbeit leisten dann auch die
entsprechenden rahmenbedingungen
vorfinden und deswegen ist es in der
verantwortung der vereinten nationen ihr
mandat eben dann auch entsprechend
auszustatten dass genau diese
voraussetzungen erfüllt sind und
sehe mich da keineswegs aus der
verantwortung zurück ich habe schon
deutlich gemacht wir sind bereit bei der
medizinischen versorgung aufzustocken
und diese verantwortung zu übernehmen
und ich habe auch versucht mit anderen
ländern zu klären welche möglichkeiten
gibt es denn hättet ihr solche
kapazitäten um diese lücke zu schließen
habe ich aber ganz viel abwinken erlebt
von verschiedenen staaten und ich habe
da auch großes verständnis dafür weil
wir alle natürlich momentan auch
militärisch unter großen
herausforderungen arbeiten müssen weil
wir anforderungen haben aus der nato aus
anderen militärbündnis und deswegen ist
es so wichtig dass die vereinten
nationen das koordiniert und das
abstimmt wenn sie dieses mandat
weiterführen ich sage ganz klar ich
finde dieses mandat ist richtig und
unser engagement ist auch wichtig wenn
die menschen leiden die menschen im
gesamten sachen leiden unter den
problemen die sie davor finden dass es
gewalt das ist terrorismus das ist
extremismus es gab zwei militärputsche
in mali es ist eines der ärmsten länder
der welt und die versorgung insbesondere
mit lebensmittel die wird jetzt noch mal
verschärft werden auch durch diesen
ukraine krieg und deswegen ist es
wichtig dass wir präsent sind das ist
auch die klare aussage dieses mandates
wir wollen das weiterführen wir wollen
weiter dafür sorgen dass das bisschen
sicherheit dass durch - mal gewähren es
wird dass es auch in zukunft sein kann
diese ganz klare botschaft senden der
von hier mit diesem mandat genauso aber
auch die botschaft dann macht die
hausaufgaben dann sorgt dafür dass
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten für
diesen hervorragenden einsatz auch
bestmöglich geschützt sein können und
dann werden wir dieses mandat auch ford
finden genauso ist es angelegt genauso
ist es auch richtig weil wir den sahel
beide dieser region nicht sich selbst
überlassen dürfen weil wir das bisschen
sicherheit dass wir bei - mehr
gewährleistet ist weiterführen müssen
deswegen lassen sie uns alle gemeinsam
jeder davon eine möglichkeit besteht
auch gegenüber den vereinten nationen
die zeit die wir noch haben deutlich
machen wir bleiben da wir leisten
unseren beitrag wir helfen zur
stabilisierung beizutragen aber dann
müsst ihr auch dafür sorgen dass die
voraussetzungen erfüllt sind deswegen
bitte ich um unterstützung für dieses
mandat
[Applaus]
1400 soldatinnen und soldaten sollen
hier bei diesem mandat nach mali gesandt
werden können das ist eine erhöhung wie
und verteidigt wurde das eben von der
bundesverteidigungsminister in lambrecht
präsidentin die werte kollegen
ministerin
bereits zu den mandatsverlängerungen von
minus 20 20 und 20 21 haben wir das
scheitern der bundeswehreinsätze in mali
festgestellt erst im februar diesen
jahres haben wir im rahmen einer
aktuellen stunde die sofortige
beendigung von minus x und eu tm
gefordert die frage die zentrale frage
stellt sich doch wessen interessen dient
unsere militärische präsenz im saal
letztendlich noch
und es ist mehr als legitim zu fragen ob
die lage in mali überhaupt noch eine
friedenssicherung mission zulässt und
inwiefern die anwesenheit
internationaler truppen die situation
für die menschen doch eher
verschlechtert hat
die bundesregierung sollte die
erkenntnis samuel huntington akzeptieren
dass ein militärisches engagement in
einem kulturell fremden land langfristig
wohl zum scheitern verurteilt ist
die ehemalige kolonialmacht frankreich
intervenierte auf bitten der malischen
regierung und mit belehrungen des un
sicherheitsrates im jahr 2013 und
stoppte mit der operation zerfall den
angriff der cellisten auf den süden
mariks die französische geführte
nachfolger operation war keine hat dann
ab 2014 den kampf gegen den terrorismus
im gesamten saal geführt - mal als un
friedensmission in mali soll dagegen
stabilisierend auf staat und armee
wirken und die bevölkerung vor
übergriffen schützen
terrorbekämpfung ist nicht mandats
inhalt von - man
die deutsche beteiligung an - mal
beschränkte sich anfangs auf
lufttransport und luftbetankung mit
maximal 150 soldaten und war in erster
linie wohl der deutsch französischen
freundschaft geschuldet
ab 2016 wurden auch bodengebundene
kräfte eingesetzt und der mandats rahmen
auf 650 soldaten erhöht der bekannte
effekt des mission creep also der
schleichenden auftrags ausweitung führte
nun jahr für jahr zur erweiterung der
eingesetzten fähigkeiten und zur
erhöhung des deutschen beitrags derzeit
wie gehört bereits
1100 soldaten
diese friedensmission - eine sogenannte
robuste mission unter kapitel 7 der un
charta ist inzwischen eine der
verlustreichsten
un-missionen seit dem koreakrieg mehr
als 260 soldaten des der internationalen
truppe sind bisher gefallen ein
mehrfaches zum teil schwer verletzt
die zahl der seit beginn der operation
in mali getöteten zivilisten soll
bereits die 8000er marke überschritten
haben allein im jahr 2020 mehr als 1000
die stiftung wissenschaft und politik
beschreibt den einsatz der bundeswehr
deshalb als wirkungslos
und weil sich die deutschen soldaten
militärisch zurückhielten ich denke
dagegen es war und ist richtig und
uneingeschränkt zu begrüßen wenn die
deutschen kommandeure die risiken für
ihre soldaten minimieren
frankreich und insbesondere der malische
armee wird dagegen oft eine akkus zu
hartes vorgehen und auch
menschenrechtsverletzungen vorgeworfen
es wird berichtet dass malische
sicherheitskräfte für mehr vergehen an
der zivilbevölkerung verantwortlich sein
sollen als die aufständischen die er
dass
das verhältnis mal ist zur ehemaligen
kolonialmacht frankreich hat sich in den
letzten monaten drastisch verschlechtert
und schließlich zur beendigung der
zusammenarbeit geführt frankreich und
seine partner haben daraufhin die
operation keine abgebrochen und werden
circa 5000 soldaten aus mali abziehen
der prozess läuft
die zweifel an der sinnhaftigkeit der
bundeswehreinsätze in mali sind also
alle kommen sie bitte zum schluss auch
die werbeauftritte des bundestages an
öffentlich die kritische überprüfung der
einsatz in mali angemalt hintergrund
sind die jüngsten putsche haben und dann
kommen sie in der regel seiner freiheit
mit wagner und anderen russischen
kräften die erfahrungen aus afghanistan
sollten also noch frisch seien daher
währte kollegen werte ministerin wollen
wir uns und raclette aus mali zurück
wenn wir das deutsche - mehr beteiligung
ich danke
joachim wundrak war das für die afg
fraktionen sitzt auch im auswärtigen
ausschuss für seine fraktion hier erst
einmal in der debatte zum - mal ein satz
der blauhelm missionen in mali nächster
redner ist marcus faber für die fdp
fraktion
der verteidigungspolitische sprecher
warum sind wir einmal moment sehen wir
demnächst sogar bis zu 1400 soldatinnen
und soldaten in die un mission - und wie
gewährleisten wir deren sicherheit in
mali und in der gesamten zone sind
islamistische terrorgruppen wie die es -
aktiv die die stabilität der region
gefährden ohne die un mission minustah
würde das die lage noch deutlich
verschlechtern
und sie würde auch auf andere länder
übergreifen sie würde fluchtursachen
schaffen das betrifft uns am ende auch
in europa und das betrifft uns am ende
auch in deutschland bekannter kuba die
beiden anti-terror-mission der franzosen
werden beendet
dadurch steigt die unsicherheit massiv
es wird ein vakuum hinterlassen dass es
zu füllen geht und dieses vakuum müssen
auch ein stück weit wie er für meine
damen und herren denn wenn wir es nicht
füllen dann werden es andere füllen dann
werden das herum in liezen füllen dann
ganz schlepperbanden füllen und dann
wird es auch organisierte kriminalität
füllen und das sollten wir vermeiden
und wie
und die französischen streitkräfte
unterhalten die essentielle fähigkeiten
auch für unseren einsatz auch für die
sicherheit der bundeswehr
luftunterstützung zum beispiel muss auch
nach dem abzug der französischen
kampfhubschrauber weiter gewährleistet
werden um unsere patrouillen hier zu
schützen leider können wir unsere
kampfhubschrauber tiger nicht entsenden
da wir unter dem cdu csu geführten
verteidigungsministerium eine
katastrophale einsatzbereitschaft
übernommen haben nicht nur in diesem
bereich und die müssen wir jetzt
verbessern deswegen sind wir hier auf
drittes partner angewiesen deswegen sind
wir hier auf bündnispartner angewiesen
und ich bin dieser bundesregierung sehr
dankbar dass sie sich darum bemüht dass
die vereinten nationen jemand anderen
finden der luftunterstützung
bereitstellt und ist auch wichtig dass
der mandatstext so geschrieben ist das
wenn das ende des sommers anfang des
herbst nicht gelingt dass wir dann auch
mit dem teilabzug beginnen denn wir
können dort nur sein wenn wir auch
sinnvoll etwas beitragen können das wäre
eine katastrophe wenn wir hier gehen
aber wir müssen eben sehen dass wir
nicht gehen müssen weil dann andere
folgen würden
meine damen und herren während unseres
einsatz in dem die soldatinnen und
soldaten große entbehrungen in kauf wir
haben es eben schon gehört weil bis zu
45 grad im schatten in einem land das
von wassermangel gibt beträgt ist ist es
für uns nicht vermeidbar dass wir den
soldaten und soldaten im einsatz zumuten
müssen dass sie mit zwei minuten duschen
am tag klarkommen müssen was wir aber
vermeiden können ist dass wir sie mit zu
wenig kampflosen für eine mehrtägige
patrouille losschicken was wir vermeiden
können ist das nicht für jeden soldaten
auch ein rucksack dabei ist sondern für
manche kampf tage taschen das war das
was ich zuletzt gehört habe als ich in
grau und in mali war und deswegen es ist
absolut richtig dass diese
bundesregierung in die persönliche
ausrüstung investiert dass wir letzten
monat 2,4 milliarden euro in genommen
haben damit ihnen die soldatinnen und
soldaten nicht nur in mali bestmöglich
ausgestattet sind sondern auch hier bei
uns zu hause das ist bei jedem mandat
wichtig aber bei gerade bei einem so
gefährlichen und zu widrigen wie diesem
hier deswegen stehen wir freie
demokraten zu diesem mandat gerade mit
dieser konditionierung deswegen
unterstützen wir das mandat weiß
zivilisten vor terror schützen wir
unterstützen ist weil das organisierte
kriminalität bekämpft und wir
unterstützen ist weil dieses mandat
schlepperbanden die arbeitsgrundlage
entzieht deutschland leistet hier viel
deutschland leistet luftaufklärung
deutschland leistet patrouillen die
zivilbevölkerung auch in die fläche
bringen und deutschland leistet
demnächst auch noch mehr nämlich sanität
sanität auch für andere nationen die an
diesen gefährlichen un mission
teilnehmen deswegen sagen wir als freie
demokraten wir unterstützen diese
mission nicht uneingeschränkt aber in
dieser kondition ali sierung ist sie
absolut richtig wir geben anderen
ländern eine chance hier in die
fehlstelle die frankreich produziert
einzutreten und deswegen sagen wir ja zu
- mann und ich danke für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
ich hatte heute das wort sieben titel in
fraktion die linke
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
die bundesregierung will den bundeswehr
einsatz im rahmen der un mission
minustah in magie nicht nur verlängern
jetzt nachdem die franzosen abziehen
wollen wollen sie den einsatz sondern
noch ausweiten durch die anhebung der
mandatsobergrenze auf 1400 soldaten also
mehr noch als zuletzt in afghanistan sie
sprechen dabei von einem
sicherheitspolitischen engagement
deutschlands das ist die formel die wir
aus 20 jahren krieg in afghanistan
kennen wie in afghanistan soll es alles
seien in mali nur kein krieg in dem
schon mehr als 4000 zivilisten gestorben
sind sie sagen die bundeswehr sei zur
umsetzung des friedensabkommens dort in
mali doch den frieden gibt es nicht die
sicherheitslage hat sich stets
verschlechtert mit der zeit dass alle
gesprächspartner und auf der reise
gesagt das land ist sogar zunehmend
militarisiert die bewaffneten konflikte
haben sich vom norden nach zentral mali
und auch in die regionen ausgedehnt sie
wollen den terrorismus in mali bekämpfen
auf afghanistan wissen wir terror
bekämpft man nicht mit krieg meine damen
und herren und man bekämpft ihn auch
nicht mit krieg indem man die förderer
von islamistischem terror banden wie
katar und saudi arabien als partner
betrachtet und sie aufrüstet wie die
staatsministerin katja keul das noch
früher gesagt hat die ganz große
kriegskoalition in diesem haus von union
bis grüne kann es noch so oft leugnen
tatsache ist deutschland ist beteiligt
an einem krieg in mali und erkennen sie
es auch endlich an dieser krieg der
bundeswehr in mali ist verloren vieles
daran erinnert an afghanistan und sie
machen die auch zu einem zweiten
afghanistan und der einzige grund warum
sie dort krieg führen ist ja noch nicht
einmal weil sie selbst daran glauben
einem sieg über den islamistischen
terror dort erringen zu können nein die
bundeswehr selbst sagt ich zitiere aus
den unterlagen die wir bekommen haben
dieser einsatz kann eine
verschlechterung der sicherheitslage
nicht verhindern zitat ende die
bundeswehr kommandeure haben es vor ort
bestätigt sie sagen es geht ihnen nicht
darum
es geht ihnen schlicht darum dass sie
einen geopolitischen fußabdruck der mann
sagt verpönt dazu nennen sie es in mali
und in der region deshalb sind sie dort
sie führen dort mit krieg damit die mali
tische malische putschregierung nicht
noch mehr große militärberater ins land
holt und das ist meines erachtens ein
purer wahnsinn und zeigt es geht um
geopolitik und nicht um die bevölkerung
in marley & ich warne auch davor
ich warne auch davor dass sich hier das
bild verstetigt die bundeswehr würde die
wirtschaftsinteressen der ehemaligen
kolonialmacht frankreich hier im sahel
unterstützen bei im mandatstext betont
wird die unterstützung französischer
streit und sicherheitskräfte
die zu recht in mali verhasst sind diese
entwicklung kann nur in einer
katastrophe enden deshalb sagen wir wir
kommen nur aus diesem schlamassel raus
werden wir die bundeswehr dort
abziehen die bundeswehr-soldaten haben
selbst gesagt muss ich komme zum schluss
der satz der bundeswehr soldaten war ist
dieser einsatz leib und leben der
soldaten wert wir linken sagen nein ist
es nicht deshalb sollte die bundeswehr
abgezogen werden
dagdelen die sprecherin für
abrüstungspolitik und internationale
politik der
schon hat hier gesprochen und der
nächste rehnas aus der spd-fraktion
karamba diaby
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren so frau kollegin ich
wunder mich sehr über ihre behauptung
bundeswehr führt krieg in mali sie waren
doch mit mir im gau sie haben doch diese
einsatz dort gesehen die wunde mit sehr
sehr dass ich die behauptung hier machen
es geht vielmehr was anderes ersten
april habe ich ja mit unserer bundes
außenministerin abhebe reise nach mali
und niger begleitet
mir ist besonders das gespräch in mali
mit mariana egal lehrerin ausbau in
erinnerung geblieben da waren sie auch
dabei sie berichtete mir uns das land
leidet unter terrorismus instabilität
und den folgen der klimakrise mali ist
wirtschaftlich schwer von den corona
pandemie gebeutelt und hat auch mit den
folgen der ukraine krise zu kämpfen das
angebot für grundnahrungsmittel
verknappt sich
tätig und die preise steigen stetig
mariam us forderungen waren eindringlich
wir dürfen unser engagement in mali
nicht beenden wir du von den schutz der
zivilbevölkerung nicht vernachlässigen
deutschland ist in mali willkommen
wenn wir also heute über unser
engagement in mali diskutieren dann
müssen wir die menschen vor ort im blick
haben und diese benötigen unsere
unterstützung genau deshalb beteiligen
wir uns an - in mali seit 2013
multilateral und die mission hat den
entscheidenden auftrag das
friedensabkommen von algier umzusetzen
und die zivilbevölkerung vor ort zu
schützen
zu den aufgaben gehören die
stabilisierung wichtige
bevölkerungszentren
der schutz der zivilbevölkerung
die unterstützung humanitärer hilfe und
die forderung der verständigung zwischen
den politischen gruppierungen aber auch
die vermittlung zwischen ecowas und der
regierung - mal ist aktuell das einzige
instrument zu stabilisierung in mali
unser engagement trägt aber nicht nur
zur stabilität marlies bei sondern
stärkte gesamten region und diese
stabilität ist dringend notwendig meine
damen und herren wir haben und nun in
mali in tschad in guinea und burkina
faso
erlebt diskussion in mali
wäre das eine katastrophe für die
gesamte region
fest steht aber auch der abzug von
frankreich erschwert die für die
weiterführung des bundeswehreinsatzes
ist unsere beteiligung in aktueller form
nur möglich wenn erstens gewährleistet
werden kann dass unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten ausreichend geschützt sind
zweitens die bestehende infrastruktur
vorhanden bleibt und drittens die un
sicherstellt dass anderer truppensteller
fähigkeit ist luft nach unterstützung
zur verfügung stellen
meine sehr verdrängt werden der schutz
unserer soldatinnen und soldaten ist
jetzt wichtiger als jemals zuvor denn
wir beobachten schon länger das muss
sich an gruppen in mali aktiv sind
darum begrüße ich die
personalaufstockung auf
es ist richtig dass wir unter den
erschwerten bedingungen den
bundeswehreinsatz ehemaligen bewerten
und hinterfragt und es ist auch richtig
dass das mandat auch vorzeitig beendet
wird wenn eben nicht mehr ausreichender
schutz unserer soldatinnen und soldaten
gewährleistet werden kann klar ist aber
auch ohne den bundeswehr-einsatz können
wir unter den bedingungen unserer
entwicklungszusammenarbeit in also
schwer fortsetzen nur mit hilfe von
windows ma können ngo s und
internationale organisationen engagiert
erzählt zusammenarbeit betreibt
meine damen und herren deutschland ist
in mali willkommen jedes engagement
müssen wir nutzen und gemeinsam mit
unseren europäischen partnern und der
regionale organisationen abgestimmt
zusammenzuarbeiten
eine kurzfristige beendigung unseres
engagement in mali wäre eine fatale ist
ideal und würde besonders im gau eine
großes vakuum hinterlassen wenn wir über
den einsatz der bundeswehr in mali
entscheiden muss der schutz der
bevölkerung unserer richtlinie sei wir
dürfen den menschen in mali nicht im
stich lassen dankeschön
karamba diaby war das hat dafür geworden
dass die menschen den magie nicht in
stich gelassen werden
und damit kommen wir in dieser debatte
zum letzten redner das ist henning otte
mitglied im verteidigungsausschuss der
union
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren deutschland hat ein
vitales interesse an der stabilität in
der sahelzone und an der sicherheit im
land mali denn die sicherheit
deutschlands endet eben nicht am
mittelmeer und es muss verhindert werden
dass von mali aus der esterer ein
brückenkopf bilden kann um europa zu
gefährden und es muss verhindert werden
dass die al kaida ableger jane das land
mali nach innen gefährden und hier zu
einer die stabilität verführen wir
danken den soldatinnen und soldaten der
bundeswehr die diesen gefährlichen
einsatz unter schwierigen klimatischen
bedingungen erfolgreich leisten ihnen
gehört unser dank meine damen und herren
und eben weil dieses mandat auch wichtig
aber vor allem auch gefährlich ist
irritiert es ja dass dieses mandat zum
spät jetzt vom kabinett
eingereicht wird dieser eindruck zu spät
und zu zögerlich macht sich ja insgesamt
in der ampel regierung breit diese
zögerlichkeit zeigt sich bei der antwort
auf den krieg in der ukraine diese
auf die krise in mali und offensichtlich
ist der konflikt innerhalb dieser ampel
koalition das bestimmende element und
das darf es nicht sein meine damen und
herren man wundert sich aber auch über
die linke und über die kfd mit beiden
rednern die ganz nach dem motto augen
zum kopf in den sand agieren wollen aber
was einfach sachlich falsch ist dass sie
einen bezug herstellen zu afghanistan
entweder sind sie nicht gut informiert
oder wissentlich informieren sie die
öffentlichkeit falsch zwei dinge sind
nämlich komplett anders in der magie
geht man von insolventen ungefähr unter
5000 aus in afghanistan waren es weit
über 100.000 in mali haben wir ein
konstruktives umfeld mit der
afrikanischen union mit eco was
beispielsweise eine ganz ganz andere
situation und sie sollten den menschen
hier keine unwahrheiten von diesem platz
aus
zu gerieren
wir werden als union ganz genau diesen
texte beraten ich stelle fest dass
beispielsweise auch die einer 90 heide
flieger aus meinem wahlkreis nicht zu
der zeit zurückkommen zu der ihnen diese
rückkehr zugesichert war sondern zu spät
kommt jetzt hier die ablösung aber was
uns ganz besonders wichtig ist das ist
der schutz unserer soldaten und da
müssen wir feststellen dass durch den
geplanten abzug der franzosen dieser
schutz der luft nach unterstützung fehlt
und die bundesministerin der
verteidigung hat keine nachfolger bisher
gefunden und außerdem ist für uns die
versorgung wichtig das heißt auch dass
der flughafen militärisch geführt wird
hier hat die
bundesministerin offensichtlich nicht
erfolgreich interveniert bei den
vereinten nationen und bundeskanzler
stolz hätten die gelegenheit gehabt mit
präsident mark rohr am montag bei seinem
besuch darauf hinzuweisen dass es auch
eine gemeinsame europäische aufgabe ist
hier die interessen so deutlich zum
ausdruck zu bringen und dass beide
ministerinnen hier sprechen und offen
die defizite ansprechen macht es ja
nicht besser sie müssen lösungen bieten
für dieses mandat um meine damen und
herren für uns ist es wichtig dass wir
eben dieses schutz und versorgungsniveau
auch gewährleisten können klar eine
absolute sicherheit kann es nicht geben
aber zu sagen wir erhöhen die
mandatsobergrenze von 1000 auf 1400 ja
da machen sie sich aber ein bisschen
einfach die bundeswehr soll es mal
wieder richten nein sie haben die
politische führung und die aufgabe den
schutz zu gewährleisten meine damen und
herren es
ist auch versäumt worden der malischen
regierung mal deutlich ins buch zu
schreiben dass sie die kooperation mit
den russischen söldnern sein lassen soll
dass das nicht der richtige weg ist um
mal in eine stabile situation zu bringen
besser wäre es die malischen soldaten so
auszubilden dass sie selbst in der lage
sind die sicherheit zu gewährleisten
aber auch da plant die bundesregierung
offensichtlich die reduzierung des
engagements
tm mandat das ja nachher dort beraten
wird das ist besser geht zeigt auch
niger da wird gut ausgebildet durch die
bundeswehr nämlich die nigrischen bei
spezialkräfte sehr erfolgreich im rahmen
der gazelle aber da planen sie dieses
mandats an zum jahresende zu beenden ich
kann nur sagen deutschland trägt
verantwortung
deutschland macht diese verantwortung
auch geltend - mandat denn
1400 soldatinnen und soldaten von einem
umfassenden 13.000 köpfigen
130000 köpfigen mandat das macht
deutlich wie wichtig der beitrag
deutschlands ist als anlehnung nationen
wir sagen aber auch diese verantwortung
muss verantwortbar sein nämlich das
mandat wir stimmen der beratung zu aber
wir sagen auch sehr deutlich wir machen
unsere zustimmung zum mandat von den
beratungen abhängig und da sind sie
gefordert als ampel und als regierung
vielen dank für die aufmerksamkeit
henning otte war das hat hier als
letzter in dieser
debatte gesprochen zum bundeswehr
einsatz in mali - mal denn es ist
natürlich unter anderem ein problem dass
frankreich nun abziehen wird bis zum
sommer hat so hat es frankreich im
februar angekündigt sollen die
französischen anti terror truppen
abziehen unter anderem nannte frankreich
behinderung durch die malische
übergangsregierung als grund und was
jetzt passieren wird weil die in mali
stationierten französischen
kampfhubschrauber ja ersetzt werden
müssen das ist noch unklar mali wird
auch noch in einer guten halben stunde
hier eine rolle spielen dann geht es um
die ausbildungsmission der eu die
weiterlaufen soll auch allerdings nicht
mehr in mali sondern im nachbarland
niger dort soll dann der schwerpunkt
stattfinden eben weil man
befürchtet dass es sonst zu
menschenrechtsverletzungen durch
malische soldaten kommt die von der
bundeswehr ausgebildet
bis es dazu kommt beschäftigen wir uns
mit einem ganz anderen thema nämlich der
unterbringung in entziehungsanstalt 'nen
wenn eine person eine straftat begeht
und dabei allerdings in einem
rauschzustand war dann kann es sein dass
sie nicht verurteilt wird wegen
schuldunfähigkeit oder zwar verurteilt
wird aber die unterbringung in einer
entziehungsanstalt angeordnet wird und
seit jahren steigt die zahl der
untergebrachten straftäter und deswegen
hat die unionsfraktion hier einen
gesetzentwurf
eingebracht um diesen strafparagrafen zu
ändern und als erstes für die
unionsfraktion spricht axel müller
denn wer die kolleginnen kollegen schon
bei der vorstellung des themas hat man
gemerkt beim vorlesen des heutigen tops
es ist schwere kost die ich ihnen jetzt
vortragen werde und die sich aber auch
nicht für politische
richtungsstreitigkeiten einigt sondern
allenfalls zum juristischen diskurs aber
das thema ist wichtig weil es um das
schicksal der menschen auf der einen
seite aber auch um die sicherheit der
bevölkerung auf der anderen seite geht
einer aktuellen pressemitteilung der
heilbronner stimme war zu in dem das
rechtskräftig verurteilte straftäter aus
der sogenannten organisations haft
entlassen werden mussten weil sie nicht
in den maßregelvollzug überführt werden
konnten denn dort waren keine therapie
plätze mehr frei in 2021 waren das in
baden württemberg in 35 fällen der fall
in 20 22 ist es bereits in 17 fällen so
vorgekommen aber das problem ist um da
keinen falschen eindruck zu erwecken
kein spezifisch baden württemberg
sondern ein bundesweites und die
vermeintlich einfachste lösung der
aufbau mehr von mehr plätzen im
maßregelvollzug
hat bisher nicht gegriffen der
maßregelvollzug geregelt in den
paragraphen 64 ford folgen des
strafgesetzbuchs sieht vor dass neben
einer verurteilung zu einer
freiheitsstrafe man nennt das die
sogenannte begleit strafe auch eine
unterbringung der maßregel der war es
wirklich verbesserungen angeordnet
werden kann voraussetzung ist dass die
verurteilte person einen hang hat
alkoholische getränke oder berauschende
mittel zu sich zu nehmen und in diesem
zusammenhang dann auch straftaten begeht
und des weiteren muss von dieser person
dann die gefahr ausgehen dass aufgrund
dieses hannes ist auch zu weiteren
gefährlichen straftaten kommt die
unterbringung soll allerdings nur
erfolgen wenn eine hinreichend konkrete
der handlungs erfolgsaussicht bestehen
grundsätzlich soll dabei die begleit
strafe vor der therapeutisch
orientierten maßregel vollzogen werden
allerdings hat das gericht bei der
vollstreckung reihenfolge diaz welt zu
beachten dass der zweck der maßregel wie
es so schön heißt leichter erreicht wird
und das soll dadurch geschehen dass die
gerichte es vermeiden dass ich an einem
möglicherweise erfolgreiche therapie
eine weitere strafvollstreckung
anschließt und dazu haben sie bei der
festlegung der reihenfolge und bei der
berechnung ganz konkret den halb strafen
zeitpunkt in den blick zu nehmen das ist
der zeitpunkt zu dem frühest möglich
eine bedingte haftentlassung vorgenommen
werden kann und der halb strafen
zeitpunkt kommt in der praxis beim
normalen strafvollzug so gut wie nie vor
und man ahnt es was ich jetzt da ergibt
daraus nämlich besondere
verteidigungsstrategien die darauf
abzielen insbesondere bei langjährigen
begleiter strafen eine überführung in
den maßregelvollzug zu bekommen und da
ein wesentliches indiz dass diese
fehlanreize bestehen ist die tatsache
dass mittlerweile zwei drittel der im
maßregelvollzug befindlichen personen
voll schuldfähig waren bei der begehung
ihrer tat das ist eine verdreifachung
der bisherigen zahlen und ein
eindrucksvoller beleg dass etwas schief
läuft beim maßregelvollzug sind dann
auch die von zwölf bundesländern
erhobenen und gemeldeten zahlen danach
stieg die zahl der untergebrachten im
zeitraum 2002 bis 2009 10 um mehr als
das doppelte von 2088 auf 4300 personen
und in der kurzen zeit von 2017 bis 2020
war es ein anstieg von enormen 18
prozent sind jetzt bei fast 5300
unterbringen in der gleichen zeit stieg
die dauer der stationären behandlungen
aber auf 18 monate was räumliche und
personelle kräfte zusätzlichen anspruch
nimmt ein erster gesetzgeberischer
eingriff im jahr 2007 brachte er war
nicht weit genug keine wirkliche
besserung und jetzt platzt der
maßregelvollzug wahrlich aus allen
nähten und gefährliche straftäter vor
denen eigentlich die allgemeinheit
geschützt werden müssen können dort
nicht zugeführt werden und müssen wie
eingangs erwähnt auf freien fuß gesetzt
werden bundesländer haben sich deshalb
bereits 2020 zu einer arbeitsgruppe
zusammengeschlossen und haben 2021 im
november einen konzertierten
gesetzesvorschlag vorgelegt aber auch
nach fast einem halben jahr hat es die
bundesregierung nicht geschafft diesen
vorschlag hier einzubringen und die
wesentlichen gibt es dafür drei
lösungsansätze um die erwähnten probleme
bereiche zu lösen erstens man muss den
unbestimmten rechtsbegriff des hangs in
paragraf 64 präzisieren das geschieht in
unserem entwurf weil nämlich oftmals
dieser kann auf der bloßen annahme der
angaben des angeklagten festgestellt
wird und nicht weiter überprüfbar ist
und wir wollen dadurch eine substanz
konsum störung einführen die auf
bestimmte begleiterscheinungen haben
muss die auch konkret festzustellen sind
um diesen weiten begriff einzuengen
und es muss die straftat überwiegend und
nicht nur als begleit tat des hanges
geschehen und auch das muss festgestellt
werden
zweitens wir verlangen nach § 64 absatz
2 dass die bisherige lediglich konkrete
aus sicht eines behandlungserfolg
zukünftig so geschrieben wird das ein
ganz konkreter aufgrund tatsächlicher
anhaltspunkte festzustellen und zu
erwarten der behandlungserfolg der fall
sein wird der in wirklichkeit
therapieunwillige von mir beschriebene
mehrfachtäter der häufig sehr häufig in
von der rechtsprechung immer noch mit
dem weiteren maßregelvollzug bedient
wird fällt damit aus dem kreis der
personen die in den maßregelvollzug
kommen heraus und drittens die bisher
eingangs beschriebene voll begleit
strafe die beim vorweg vollzug zu
berücksichtigen ist die muss so
ausgestaltet werden dass eine
frühestmögliche haftentlassung nicht
mehr zum halb strafen zeitpunkt sondern
erst zum zwei drittel zeitpunkt
stattfinden kann und dann sind die
beschriebenen fehlanreize beseitigt das
geschieht durch eine änderung des
paragraphen 67 absatz 5 stgb die übrigen
vorgeschlagenen gesetzesänderung sind
rein technischer natur und dienen einer
verbesserung des verfahrens ablaufs und
ich denke ich habe nicht so viel
versprochen wenn ich eingangs gesagt
habe schwere kost und kein tummelfeld
für parteipolitischen zwist und es
bedarf die märkte geht im konstruktiven
schnellen gemeinsamen gesetzgeberischen
kraftanstrengung von opposition und
regierung und die bieten wir mit unserem
entwurf heute ernsthaft an und ich freue
mich auf die folgende beratungen
axel müller war das und wir können
gespannt sein ob es hier wirklich viel
streit in den beratungen gibt denn auch
bundesjustizminister marco buschmann hat
schon angekündigt zeitnah ein reform
info vorzulegen und will dabei auch die
empfehlungen der
bund-länder-arbeitsgruppe
berücksichtigen johannes fechner jetzt
für die sozialdemokraten
strafe verurteilt wurde wird nicht
einfach weggesperrt wird sondern dass er
eine chance bekommt sich zu bessern und
sich zu resozialisieren und versucht
kranke straftäter die die straftat für
die sie einsetzen im aus begangen haben
für diese straftäter sollen gerichtet
die unterbringung in einer
entziehungsanstalt anordnen wenn die
gefahr besteht so die heutige
formulierung dass infolge des hanges zu
berauschenden mitteln oder alkoholischen
getränken die person weiter
rechtswidrige taten begehen könnte das
zeigt wir geben straftätern eine chance
sich zu bessern durch den
maßregelvollzug das ist ein ganz
wichtiges element unseres
rechtsstaatlichen strafvollzugs liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das möchte ich
gleich eingangs betont
bevor ich dann aber strafrechtliche
ausführungen mache möchte ich nenne es
mal eine urheberrechtliche hinweis geben
denn man könnte ja wenn man den antrag
ließ und auch die rede hört und auf die
pressemitteilung meinen es wäre die
union hätte sich mit diesem wichtigen
thema beschäftigt hätte vorschläge
erarbeitet das ist ja gerade nicht der
fall was sie hier präsentieren das haben
sie abgeschrieben das ist eins zu eins
das ergebnis der kommission die
ministerin lamprecht eingesetzt hat sie
zeigt interesse an dem thema auch jetzt
noch ein star und dass wir nicht ist
schon eine schräge nummer sie hätten
doch wenigstens mit einem satz mal sagen
können dass sie die vorschläge die die
bund länder kommission erarbeitet hat
ich lasse es mal so stehen will aber die
gelegenheit nutzen ein ganz herzliches
dankeschön an alle zu richten von dieser
stelle die in diese kommission
mitgearbeitet haben die gute vorschläge
hier präsentiert haben die wir
diskutieren werden ganz herzlichen dank
wir haben in der tat das problem dass zu
viele straftäter durch
gerichtsbeschlüsse in entziehungsanstalt
untergebracht werden die dort aber
eigentlich gar nicht hingehören und
diese straftäter in demjenigen
straftätern dann die plätze weg die dort
denen dort eigentlich geholfen werden
sollte und deshalb müssen wir in der tat
dazu kommen dass nur noch die
behandlungsbedürftigen und auch
behandlungs fähigen straftäter in der
entziehungsanstalt untergebracht werden
denn die unterbringung haben sich in der
tat in den letzten jahren deutlich
erhöht seit den 90er jahren vervierfacht
und auch die aufenthaltsdauer hat sich
deutlich erhöht und das merke ich auch
bei mir im wahlkreis kollegin engelhardt
auch unter kollegen müller wir haben
solche einrichtungen die platzen aus
allen nähten und können insbesondere
diejenigen die dringend hilfe benötigen
für die wir dieses konstrukt des
maßregelvollzuges haben nicht in
anspruch nehmen und das wollen wir
ändern deswegen haben wir schon im
koalitionsvertrag festgelegt dass wir
den maßregelvollzug modernisieren und
reformieren wollen und die ergebnisse
der bund-länder-kommission die finde ich
bieten dafür wirklich eine sehr sehr
gute diskussionsgrundlage in der tat
muss die vorschrift dieser werden des
paragrafen 64 des strafgesetzbuches das
tatbestandsmerkmal des hanges zu
alkoholischen getränken oder suchtmittel
ist zu weit gefasst das müssen wir
präzisieren und zu diskutieren ist auch
der vorschlag der kommission die
anforderungen an den behandlungserfolg
zu erhöhen das heißt dass eine anordnung
zur unterbringung nur dann ergehen darf
wenn tatsächliche anhaltspunkte erwarten
lassen dass der straftäter durch die
behandlung in der entziehungsanstalt
wirklich von seiner sucht auch wegkommt
und wir werden auch den vorschlag der
kommission diskutieren dass das privileg
der halt strafen aussetzung geändert
werden sollte so der vorschlag denn
heute kann die strafe aus mission dass
das anreize schafft insbesondere für
straftäter die eine lange haftstrafe
bekommen haben sich in den
maßregelvollzug zu bewegen das wollen
wir auch auf jeden fall diskutieren
darüber werden wir beraten in der
ampelkoalition denn eins ist klar wir
dürfen keine fehlanreize die ersetzen
was die falschen straftäter den
straftätern dieser behandeln wollen die
knappen ressourcen in der
entziehungsanstalt wegnehmen ich finde
das lohnt sich und wir freuen uns hier
auch die diskussion auch dieses antrags
der die arbeit der
bund-länder-kommission hier zu recht in
der öffentlichkeit rückt vielen dank
und das wort hat thomas schaaf die
fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren eine
unterbringung nach § 64 stgb bedeutet
dass straftäter mit suchtproblemen
zwangsweise in eine forensische
erziehungs einrichtung eingewiesen
werden können vor allem bei hohen
haftstrafen bewirbt dies häufig eine
frühere entlassung wie sieht also die
realität des maßregelvollzugs aus allein
im zeitraum von 2002 bis 20 19 hat sich
die zahl der patienten mehr als
verdoppelt und sich der anteil voll
schuldfähig von 1995 bis 2009 10 fast
verdreifacht bereits ende 20 20 konnten
die zustände in berliner maßregelvollzug
nur noch als katastrophal bezeichnet
werden was zu mehreren brandbriefen an
den ball hinter senat führte das
hauptproblem war überbelegung 2009 10
waren es im durchschnitt
682 patienten bei nur 5 123 genehmigten
betten also gut 30 prozent überbelegung
als folge massiv zunehmende gewalt gegen
mitarbeiter und ein sich verschärfender
personalmangel kündigungen und keine
bewerbungen mehr allein aus berlin
wurden für das jahr 2019 rund 180
angriffe auf mitarbeiter in der
erziehungs einrichtung gemeldet von
körperverletzung bis zur versuchten
tötung
aktuell liegt dem rechtsausschuss ein
brandbrief aus dem zentrum für
psychiatrie südwürttemberg vor die
beschriebenen probleme erinnern an
berlin die zimmer sind bis zu mit bis zu
vier patienten in stockbetten belegt man
nimmt also personen mit häufig
psychischen begleiterkrankungen neben
der sucht mit einem regelmäßig gestörtem
sozialverhalten und ausgesprochen
niedrige frustrationstoleranz
jeglicher rückzugsmöglichkeit
was wären latente aggressivität noch
steigert weiter wird beklagt dass offene
stellen nicht mehr besetzt werden
stattdessen steigt die krankheits
steigen die krankheitsausfälle beim
personal es war deshalb dringend
überfällig dass im herbst 2020 eine
gemeinsame bund länder arbeitsgruppe
eingesetzt wurde und den von der
arbeitsgruppe erarbeiteten gesetzentwurf
greift nunmehr der antrag der union auf
kern der vorgeschlagenen änderungen ist
im wesentlichen die anordnung
voraussetzung des hangs zu alkohol
beziehungsweise drogen enger zu fassen
in dem künftig das vorliegen einer
substanz konsum störung festgestellt
werden muss weiterhin wenn ein
zwingender zusammenhang zwischen hang
und anders tat hergestellt es soll nicht
mehr ausreichen dass eine tat im rausch
begangen wurde sondern sie muss künftig
jedenfalls überwiegend auf den hang
zurückzuführen sein zudem werden die
anforderungen an die prognose eines
therapieerfolgs verschärft das ziel muss
es sein die kontinuierlich angestiegene
zahl der in den führungs anstalten
untergebrachten deutlich zu senken nicht
um das geld für zusätzliche
therapieplätze zu sparen sondern weil
sich in den einrichtungen derzeit zu
einem erheblichen teil personen befinden
denen es an therapie bedürftigkeit
therapiebereitschaft oder auch mangels
deutscher sprachkenntnisse oder
kultureller unterschiede schlicht an der
therapie fähigkeit fehlt
der ist-zustand bedeutet nicht nur eine
ungerechtfertigte privilegierung von
straftätern die hohe kosten verursacht
sondern vor allem auch eine
beeinträchtigung der therapie chancen
für diejenigen die wirklich einer
therapie bedürfen motiviert sind und
eine positive prognose haben soweit die
union abweichend vom entwurf der
arbeitsgruppe auch eine änderung von §
246a scp anstrebt lehnen wir dies ab um
die gerichte zu entlasten will die union
die verpflichtung zur bestellung eines
sachverständigen einschränken bisher ist
es erforderlich wenn das gericht eine
unterbringung in einer
entziehungsanstalt erwägt künftig nur
noch wenn es dies konkret erwägt eine
regelung die nach meiner prognose
weitgehend leer laufen würde so weiter
gesetzentwurf der arbeitsgruppe folgt
begrüßen wir ihnen und wir sind gespannt
welchen und auch wann das
justizministerium einen eigenen
gesetzentwurf vorlegen wird vielen dank
soweit thomas seitz der rechtspolitische
sprecher der fdp-fraktion auf ihn folgt
nun schon dann bei rahmen für bündnis 90
die grünen sie ist mitglied im
rechtsausschuss
[Applaus]
vielen dank frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen therapie statt
strafe dass es der grundsatz der mit dem
paragraphen 64 ford folgende im
strafgesetzbuch geregelt ist das heißt
suchtkranke menschen gehören nicht ins
gefängnis sondern in eine
entziehungsanstalt denn sucht ist häufig
ein auslöser für die begehung von
straftaten das sollten wir vielleicht
mal voranstellen meine damen und herren
wenn eine person mit suchterkrankungen
einfach ins gefängnis gesteckt wird dann
wird dadurch nur das symptom bekämpft
aber nicht die ursache das heißt der
oder diejenige kann dadurch leicht in
einen teufelskreis von sucht
kriminalität verurteilungen gefängnis
und wieder suchte stecken bleiben und
weil im gefängnis das problem nicht
gelöst wird geht es nach der freilassung
wieder von vorne los deswegen werden
richtigerweise nach § 64
strafgesetzbuch personen die einen hang
zu dem berauschenden mitteln haben vom
gericht zur behandlung in eine entzugs
klinik untergebracht oder in eine
entziehungsanstalt und in den letzten
jahren hat es sich tatsächlich so
entwickelt dass die zahl der personen
immer weiter gestiegen ist und weil so
die
entziehungsanstalt an ihre grenzen
insbesondere der kapazitäten gekommen
sind wurde vor etwa drei jahren eine
bund länder arbeitsgruppe gegründet um
lösungen für diese probleme zu finden im
januar diesen jahres hat diese gruppe
ihre ergebnisse vorgestellt aus ihrem
bericht geht hervor dass sich die zahl
der untergebrachten personen
in dem zeitraum 2002 bis 2009 10
tatsächlich mehr als verdoppelt haben
deswegen macht sie vorschläge mit
welchen gesetzesänderungen die zahl der
untergebrachten verringert werden soll
im wesentlichen säulen mit einer
längeren fassung des paragraphen 64
strafgesetzbuch die kliniken entlastet
werden der gesetzentwurf der
unionsfraktion
greift diesen vorschlag auf also vielen
dank erstmal an die cdu csu fraktion
dass sie den bericht der
bund-länder-arbeitsgruppe wollen wir
fair bleiben den großen teilen kopiert
haben
wir haben diesen bericht natürlich auch
gelesen und prüfen ihn intensiv denn im
koalitionsvertrag haben wir uns darauf
geeinigt dass wir das sanktionssystem
insgesamt in den blick nehmen wollen und
der maßregelvollzug ist ein teil dessen
und wir wollen das ganze
überarbeiten und für eine umfassende
reform reicht es eben nicht nur aus der
perspektive der länder die missstände zu
benennen sondern wir müssen die
einzelnen stellschrauben in den blick
nehmen und tatsächlich schauen was
können wir von der bundesebene aus
verändern wir brauchen ein gesamtkonzept
bei dem prävention und resozialisierung
im fokus stehen dass es für uns grüne
außerordentlich wichtig
denkbar wäre die kapazitäten der
einrichtungen zu erhöhen aber reicht das
ein anderer vorschlag sieht vor die
unterbringung davon abhängig zu machen
ob der oder die betroffene dem
tatsächlich zustimmt die deutsche
gesellschaft für soziale psychiatrie hat
einen vorschlag vorgelegt der eine
komplette transformation der maßregeln
vorsieht auch diesen vorschlag müssen
und wollen wir uns gemeinsam genauer
anschauen denn im mittelpunkt unserer
überlegungen muss immer stehen wie wir
dadurch die prävention und
resozialisierung beitragen können weil
es nichts bringt wenn die
entziehungsanstalt wieder viele freie
plätze haben wir dadurch aber immer mehr
straftaten durch rückfällige menschen
haben das kann der sinn dessen auch
nicht sein liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen deswegen wollen wir es genauer
prüfen denn wir können nicht riskieren
dass tatsächlich
behandlungsbedürftige straffällige
menschen nicht behandelt werden entweder
weil die kliniken überfüllt sind oder
sie ins gefängnis gesteckt werden beides
müssen wir als risiko im blick behalten
klar ist der justizvollzug allein kann
nicht die lösung sein der grundsatz
therapie vorstrafe darf nicht
aufgeweicht werden wir brauchen eine
strategie um den betreffenden angemessen
zu helfen dazu gehört auch dass es die
möglichkeit geben muss suchtkranken
menschen im justizvollzug zugang zur
substitutionsbehandlung zu ermöglichen
auf der anderen seite dürfen wir
diejenigen die wegen einer
suchterkrankung von einer maßregel
betroffen sind in den einrichtungen
nicht vergessen wenn das gericht nach
sechs monaten prüft ob die weitere
unterbringung zur bewährung ausgesetzt
wird sollte den betroffenen einen
rechtsbeistand zur seite gestellt werden
dies ist leider immer noch nicht
geregelt obwohl gerade bei der
unterbringung in einer
entziehungsanstalt oder einer
psychiatrischen einrichtung in der regel
klar ist dass die betroffenen
schwierigkeiten haben sich selbst zu
verteidigen das ist auch ein aspekt den
wir miteinander gemeinsam betrachten
sollten denn
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und da
scheinen uns übergreifend alle einig zu
sein so wie es ist kann es nicht bleiben
und deswegen werden wir als ampel
koalition gemeinsam das sanktionensystem
evidenzbasiert auf den prüfstand stellen
und dann als fortschritt koalition ein
schlüssiges gesamtkonzept vorstellt und
da freuen wir uns auf jeden wertvollen
beitrag auch aus der opposition vielen
dank
und ich hatte das dem kollegen
artischocken fraktion die linke an tisch
gewinner sprecher für toben politik
seiner fraktion präsidentin sehr geehrte
damen und herren sehr geehrter müller
ich habe am anfang gesagt dass wert hier
werden nicht zur politisierung geeignet
ich glaube wenn sie den antrag ein
bisschen früher vorstellen obwohl die
koalition unter justizminister gesagt
hat sie würden dann arbeiten und dann
ein paar sachen noch verändern da ist ja
schon ein bisschen politisierung dran
dann müssen wir euch ehrlich sein ich
darf noch mal herrn vechta verbessern es
gibt noch eine veränderung sie behaupten
dass kosten eingespart würden in dem in
der bund länder runde im
abschlussbericht steht dass keine kosten
eingespart werden weil sie die
aufenthalte in den gefängnissen jahr
verlängern wollen deswegen stimmt es
nicht ganz was sie behauptet haben auch
wenn sie quasi in ihrem vorschlag
suggerieren deswegen wäre es wirklich
gut dann nochmal genauer auf zu schauen
ich möchte aber naja vielleicht typisch
für linke noch ein bisschen mehr
politisieren frau bayern was er schon
ansatzweise angesprochen das
grundlegende problem findet sich auch
schon in anderen preise im gesetz selbst
und da ist auch schon bisher für anderes
weltbild den umgang mit suchtkranken zu
sehen ich meine der begriff
entziehungsanstalt und deutet er so ein
bisschen darauf hin dass das gesetz
nicht im jahr 2022 erfunden wurde
vielleicht können wir noch ein bisschen
mehr drüber gehen als einfach einen
entwurf vom bund vom bund länder runde
zu kopieren herr kollege müller
dann nämlich eine irrige annahme ist
eine irrige annahme menschen können
durch eine erzwungene sucht behandlung
zu einem selbstbestimmten leben
verholfen werden frau bereits
angesprochen der vorschlag ist zum
beispiel bei der deutschen gesellschaft
für psychiatrie die was anderes vorsehen
schauen sie vielleicht da mal rein und
lesen sie da ab und ist auch eine
abwegige annahme ein entzug ohne jede
hilfe beim verlassen des umfelds der
szene beim umgang mit der meist
lebenslange suchterkrankung dass es
wirklich den menschen langfristig helfen
würde genauso sind aber ihr
erziehungsanstalten bislang eigentlich
angelegt und der maßregelvollzug in
einer entziehungsanstalt
insgesamt vermischt gegenwärtig
heilbehandlungen die eben ohne
zustimmung und mitwirkung der
betroffenen meist nicht sinnvoll sind
mit den polizeirecht zur sicherung der
öffentlichen ordnung und das r müller
ich spreche ich auch direkt an sollte
dringend überdenken da gibt es nämlich
bereits vorschläge vielleicht lernen sie
doch einfach mal barras aber lassen sie
uns und aber ich komme ich zum dritten
punkt lassen uns doch einfach ein
bisschen weiter denken auch weil er
durch die debatte zur legalisierung von
cannabis und bisschen schwung in eine
sache kommt in eine nicht geringe
verantwortung für den zustand ist der
teufelskreis der aus der illegalisierung
von konsumierenden von rauschmitteln
entsteht und zunächst droht strafe
aufgrund einer handlung die niemandem
schaden zugefügt hat außer einem selbst
und das ist nirgends außer in dieser
strafe an ordnung mit strafe bedroht ab
dann kommen aber viele suchtkranke aus
dem teufelskreis der illegalisierung
nicht mehr raus und genau da müssen wir
helfen das ziel der drogen- und
suchtpolitik darf eben nicht mehr sein
die konsumierenden zu verfolgen und zwar
eben nicht nur bei cannabis sorgen für
alle illegalisierten drogensucht kranke
brauchen hilfe und zur gehhilfe gehört
weniger der rheiner entzug der oft
ohnehin kaum möglich ist und schon gar
kein gefängnis sehr verehrte damen und
herren und übersetzt und abschließend
für die cdu/csu wenn sie wirklich kosten
sparen wollen stoppen sie die bindung
von millionen arbeitsstunden bei der
polizei und staatsanwaltschaften und
lassen sie die polizei aus dem spiel
weil es über den eigenbedarf geht
entkriminalisieren sie kommen
stattdessen ich komme zum schluss
stärken wir stattdessen die
behandlungskapazitäten für die vielen
vielen menschen die hilfe etwa der
spezialisierten psychotherapie in der
substitutionsbehandlung in der
akzeptierenden drogenhilfe oder auch in
der stationären behandlung dringend
suchen vielen vielen dank
soweit die biene hier in der debatte zur
unterbringung in einer
entziehungsanstalt die plätze werden rar
deswegen gibt es handlungsbedarf denn
sowohl die opposition als auch die ampel
koalition sieht wenn der straftäter
nicht im gefängnis landen sondern in
einer psychiatrischen einrichtungen da
sorgt das oft für unverständnis bei den
opfer einer straftat bei betroffenen
auch in der öffentlichkeit aber muss
sich einfach vor augen halten dass es im
strafverfahren erst sekundär um
genugtuung für das opfer geht und für
die öffentlichkeit und um opfer
entschädigung es geht primär im
strafverfahren um wahrheitsfindung
herauszufinden war der wahre tathergang
also der objektive tatbestand und was
für eine innere motivlage hat den täter
zur tat gemacht das subjektive
tatbestand auch für an der
schuldfähigkeit des urteilsvermögens und
der geistigen erfassung des täters
spielen da eine rolle und beim
strafvollzug ist primär das ziel die
sozialisierung der es geht sicher auch
um satisfaktion genugtuung für das opfer
aber eben nicht durch drakonische
strafen der mensch wird derzeit wird
immer noch als als mensch gesehen er
soll eine chance bekommen der soll die
gelegenheit erhalten sich wieder
einzugliedern in die gesellschaft und
ein leben in sozialer verantwortung ohne
straftaten zu führen das unterscheidet
uns von zahlreichen anderen
rechtsordnungen dass der rache gedanke
bei uns zurück gedrängt ist und der
straftäter als mensch gesehen wird der
seine würde behält das verlangt uns
manchmal viel cup vor allem bei sehr
schweren straftaten es ist aber ein
zivilisatorischer fortschritt weil damen
und herren eine der vornehmsten
errungenschaften unserer rechtskultur
neben der gefängnisstrafe sieht unserer
rechtsordnung für bestimmte fälle auch
noch vor dass ein verurteilter in einer
psychiatrischen einrichtung
untergebracht werden kann das ist bei
strafgesetzbuch die voraussetzung ist
dann das trotz schuldunfähigkeit oder
verminderter schuldfähigkeit
1 2 spruch nicht betracht kommt weil der
täter für die allgemeinheit immer noch
eine gefahr darstellt weil erwartet wird
dass er erneut weitere straftaten
begehen kann so ein paar grafen
weiterhin bei den 64 strafgesetzbuch da
haben wir jetzt den fall eines einst
maßregelvollzuges die eine straffällig
gewordene person davor bewahren kann ein
haftstrafe antreten zu müssen dann
können die gerichte anordnen dass eine
straffällig gewordene person die ein
hang dazu hat alkoholische getränke oder
andere berauschende mittel zu
missbrauchen im übermaß zu sich zu
nehmen unter bestimmten voraussetzungen
in eine entziehungsanstalt untergebracht
wird und da gab's letzten jahren eben
eine deutliche entwicklung dahin dass
immer mehr menschen genau dort landen in
diesen entziehungsanstalt und dass auch
ihre durchschnittliche unterbringungs
dauer dort verlängert wird und jetzt
kommt das problem wir haben nur eine
begrenzte anzahl solcher therapieplätze
in deutschland und haben in vielen
bundesländern die kapazitätsgrenzen
bereits erreicht gut die folge ist nun
davon wenn ein solcher straftäter kein
therapieplatz bekommt dann kann er
aufgrund dieser gerichtlich entscheidung
eben nicht einfach in freiheitsstrafe
oder gebracht werden sondern müssen
zunächst in diese organisations haft
genommen werden aber auch das nicht auf
ewige zeiten sondern irgendwann wenn die
zu lange dauert dann muss er auf freien
fuß gesetzt während dann haben wir die
situation dass jemand von dem das
gericht sagte er stellt eine gefahr für
die öffentlichkeit dar wieder auf freien
fuß kommen das sind eben die 17 fälle
von den kollegen müller sprach in diesem
jahr in baden württemberg schon dazu
geführt haben dass wegen therapie
platzmangels person aus position haft
entlassen werden muss den letzten jahres
35 fälle und das ist ein eklatantes
problem dass wir ernst nehmen angehen
und lösen müssen und hintergrund ist der
ungenau formulierte maria 64
strafgesetzbuch der weite auslegung
spielräume eröffnet und auch tür und tor
für missbrauch auf macht es gibt sogar
im internet tutorials wie man ein
haftstrafe entgehen kann indem man eine
sucht abhängigkeit als als grund dafür
nimmt in einer entziehungsanstalt zu
kommen und nicht im
justizvollzug und deswegen diese bund
länder arbeitsgruppe die ein geworden
ist und ein gesetzesvorschlag vorgelegt
hat und das ist eben der punkt dass
jetzt die union den gesetzesentwurf eins
zu eins übernommen hat immerhin zwei
lernerfolge stelle ich fest erstens die
union zitiert ihre quelle auch nicht
immer so gewesen und zum zweiten sie
folgen jetzt nicht einfach nur ein
strafverschärfung reflex sondern sie
nehmen sich expertenrat zu herzen auch
das war nicht immer so in der letzten
wahlperiode ich denke zum beispiel an
die abschaffung minderschwere fälle bei
sexualdelikten oder ich denke an die
wiederaufnahme von strafverfahren bei
den beweismitteln
oder beim verbot für schwangerschafts
abbrüche wo oft nicht der expertenrat
zählte das oft genau das gegenteil
gemacht sondern wir wollen
evidenzbasierte politik betreiben und
damit komme ich zum ende frau
präsidentin wir werden natürlich die
vorstände aber es gibt bei uns zu herzen
und deswegen bräuchte es eigentlich
nicht den gesetzentwurf der union weil
er kein bedingungsloses fertigung nichts
falsches erzählt dass ich freue mich
auch die beratung im ausschuss
um nach dieser debatte wird nämlich der
gesetzentwurf der union erst einmal in
die entsprechenden ausschüsse überwiesen
und dann kommt ja auch hier wieder an zu
plenum und wie das thema wird uns also
noch beschäftigen minister redner ist
volker ullrich sprecher für rechte csu
landesgruppe
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren die bereits viel
zitierte bund länder arbeitsgruppe zur
reform des paragrafen 64 gegen
strafgesetzbuch hat ihrem bericht
bereits zu beginn diesen jahres
vorgestellt wir sind jetzt vier monate
später und es gibt noch keine anzeichen
für eine gesetzgeberische aktivität
warum haben wir also diesen antrag
gestellt weil es eine dringende
rechtspolitische notwendigkeit gibt dass
dieses thema schnell gelöst wird weil es
eine notwendigkeit ist dass wir es nicht
auch die bald lange bank schieben
weswegen die zahl der straftäter in
erziehungsanstalten ist erheblich
gestiegen es war eine neunziger jahre
noch etwa 1500 m über 5000 menschen die
dauer der unterbringung steigt auf
mindestens 18 monate im schnitt und die
anzahl der voll schuldfähigen personen
beträgt über 60 prozent deswegen sind
folgende fragen
angebracht und wir müssen sie
beantworten wir handeln wir in den
erziehungs anstalten noch die richtig
werden die mittel adäquat aufgewandt und
schließlich ist jetzige praxis gerecht
und alle diese drei fragen müssen wir
mit nein beantworten es gibt akuten
änderungsbedarf und der ist wichtig und
zwar zum einen für die menschen die
tatsächlich eine unterbringung bedürfen
um sich zu bessern und einen schutz vor
der allgemeinheit zu leisten und auf der
anderen seite für die
landesjustizverwaltungen und für die
forensischen kliniken die diese aufgabe
schultern müssen der bedarf ist
dringlich wir können nicht mehr zu
warten und vor dem hintergrund
frau brandi arbeitsgruppe erst am 13 ein
erster in ihren entwurf vorgestellt und
daher ist der bundesjustizminister
bereits dr buschmann und nicht mehr eine
von der union getragene koalition
organisieren
was wollen wir ändern
zentral rechtspolitisch wird sein dass
wir den begriff des hanges präzisieren
der begriff der drang es im paragraf 64
ja dazu geführt dass bereits jede mit
ursächlichkeit die irgendwie vorstellbar
war dazu geführt hat dass § 64 von den
gerichten gezogen worden ist wir wollen
aber und das hat auch die
bund-länder-arbeitsgruppe so gesehen es
ergänzen durch den begriff der substanz
konsum störung das ist entscheidend
warum substanz konsum störung ist ein
begriff aus der forensischen medizin und
er dient dazu dass die erkenntnisse der
forensik auch eingebettet werden in die
entsprechende anordnung damit wir
zielgenauer künftig auch im hinblick auf
den konkreten therapieerfolg diese
maßnahme verhängen können es geht darum
dass das behandlungsziel ernsthaft
erreicht werden kann und damit die
menschen diese maßnahme auch erhalten
die es wirklich brauchen es darf nicht
dazu dienen dass über den umweg des
paragrafen 64 letztlich auch für schwere
gewalttäter die halb strafe erzielt wird
obwohl eigentlich eine zweidrittel-
strafe mindestens angemessen der es auch
eine frage von materieller gerechtigkeit
auch das wollen wir damit ändern und
letzter punkt die frage
hat die union jetzt
noch zusätzliche eigene vorschläge
gemacht oder nicht ja hat sie in zwei
punkten zum einen wir wollen dass die
frage der sachverständigen nur bei
konkreten anlässen
hinzugezogen wird und damit ressourcen
zu sparen und zum zweiten der
entscheidende punkt bei einer beschwerde
wegen des wechsels von den cios anstalt
zum maßregelvollzug
wollen hier auf die aufschiebende
wirkung verzichten es geht auch hier und
die ressourcen der entsprechenden
anstalten deswegen bitten wir dass wir
vor dem hintergrund unseres vorschlages
schnell zu einer entsprechenden
rechtspolitischen umsetzung kommen die
sache ist dringlich herzlichen dank herr
soweit der rechtspolitische sprecher der
csu-landesgruppe volker ullrich damit
kommen wir zur vorletzten rednerin in
die seite partie heike engelhardt für
die spd-fraktion die frau präsidentin
kolleginnen meine damen und herren an
den bildschirmen und hier auf den
tribünen und liebe beschäftigte und
patientinnen im maßregelvollzug
seit jahren erleben wir über volle
entzugskliniken der ausbau weiterer
betten kann in den meisten bundesländern
nicht schritt halten mit dem anstieg der
zuweisungen
es kommt zur freilassung entscheidungen
aus der organisations haft wir haben es
mehrfach gehört heute wegen überlanger
wartezeiten auf einen festen freien
therapieplatz und woher rührt diese
anstieg zum einen verwenden das
bisherige gesetz den unbestimmten
begriff des hangs zu mit suchtmittel zu
konsumieren der ist dabei sehr weich
ausgelegt vor allem stelter nicht da
welcher zusammenhang zwischen diesem
hang und eine straftat besteht mir
scheint hier doch der begriff
abhängigkeit als ärztliche diagnose
besser zu passen
vor gericht werden therapie aussichten
manchmal so optimistisch ein geschäft
für personen denen eine lange haftstrafe
droht entstehen fehlanreize ihre
anwältin streben eine unterbringung in
der entziehungsklinik an gefängnis leid
im aldi vollzog und ihm das szene
bekannt sind die youtube clips mit
anleitung wie man billiger bekommt
häufig und hier reden wir im
bundesdurchschnitt von 50 prozent kommt
es zum abbruch der therapie
und in dem zusammenhang immer wieder zu
spektakulären ausbrüchen die
rückverlegung in eine haftanstalt
ansteht ich habe 15 jahre solche fälle
begleitet ich weiß um die gefahr die in
solchen situationen für die mit
patientinnen für die beschäftigten und
auch für die bevölkerung entstehen kurz
es kommen teilweise die falschen und
wenn sie da sind dann stören sie das
therapeutische milieu und gefährden den
therapieerfolg der wirklich suchtkranken
die kliniken schlagen alarm die
zuständigen ministerien in den ländern
fördern das gesetz zu überarbeiten die
bund länder arbeitsgruppe hat dazu den
vorschlag erarbeitet und er ist in
teilen druckreifen steht seit januar auf
der homepage des ministeriums
das haus buschmann vielen dank
staatssekretär strasser hat einen
referentenentwurf angekündigt und jetzt
kommt die opposition und legt einen
eigenen gesetzentwurf vor und da hat sie
einfach mal den bund länder text
abgeschrieben und damit es nicht allzu
sehr auffällt hat sie flugs eine eigene
einleitung gebastelt und ansonsten ist
im wesentlichen der texter
bund-länder-ag zu lesen die anlagen
anderer verbände etwa der deutschen
gesellschaft für psychiatrie
psychotherapie und nervenheilkunde
oder der deutschen gesellschaft für
soziale psychiatrie hat sie nicht mehr
berücksichtigt wie die union sie haben
einfach abgeschrieben und sie sich sehr
einfach gemacht zum glück ist ihr
gesetzentwurf keine doktorarbeit da gäbe
es womöglich plagiatsvorwürfe aber
immerhin
sie schreiben unter b lösungen zu
treffen selbst es werde dem ergebnis und
den handlungsempfehlungen der bund
länder ag entsprochen und 1 brauchen sie
eine zwischenfrage des kollegen nun
kollegin engert haben sie den
gesetzesentwurf durchgelesen wenn sie
das getan haben dann werden sie darin
lesen dass sich mehrfach darauf
hingewiesen habe dass dieser
gesetzentwurf im wesen liegen auf der
bund-länder-arbeitsgruppe und ihren
ergebnissen fußt und wenn sie ihn
gelesen haben weil sie es getan haben da
frage ich jetzt mal offen dann werden
sie auch festgestellt haben dass was der
kollege ulrich gerade gesagt hat wer auf
verfahrens änderungen vornehmen wollen
beispielsweise war gab es 246 klein a
stpo davon hat die
bund-länder-arbeitsgruppe nichts aber
auch gar nichts gesagt die zwischenfrage
von maxi müller als der unions fraktion
den gesetzentwurf gelesen ich stelle
mich hier nicht hin und reden über dinge
die ich nicht vorher angeschaut habe
ich sage auch sie haben zumindest
geschrieben sie haben den
handlungsempfehlungen der bund länder ag
entsprochen
1 erstaunt mich jetzt aber doch
das war meine antwort sie
aber sie dürfen aufgaben stehen bleiben
wenn das auto
[Applaus]
einfach erstaunlich jetzt doch die bund
länder ag empfiehlt nämlich die gerichte
sollen sachverständige nur hinzu hin zu
ziehen wenn sie erwägen die
unterbringung in der entziehungsanstalt
anzuordnen und die union macht daraus
jetzt sie sollen nur gehört werden die
sachverständigen wenn das gericht die
unterbringung im maßregelvollzug
konkret erweckt und genau an diesen
begriff hat sich die bund länder gruppe
abgearbeitet und schließlich auf den
begriff konkret verzichtet sie bringen
ihn jetzt wieder ins spiel mit der
empörung aus dem verband der
niedergelassenen gutachter müssen sie
umgehen damit dass sie die rechtliche
stellung suchtkranker vor gericht
schwächen würden können wir als spd
nicht einverstanden sein wir lehnen
deshalb diesen entwurf ab wir freuen uns
aber auf die konstruktive debatte wenn
demnächst hier das papier aus dem
justizministerium auf der tagesordnung
steht vielen dank
und damit kommen wir zum letzten redner
sebastian fiedler ist jetzt spd-mitglied
war bis letztem jahr auch vorsitzender
beim bund deutscher
kriminalbeamter und es jetzt sprecher
für kriminalpolitik
ich finde die debatte kann nicht zu ende
gehen ohne dass wir uns nochmal für
moment jedenfalls mit den ursachen
beschäftigen wir sprechen über
riesengroße belegungszahlen sprechen
über das verfahren an sich wie man das
ändern kann und damit umzugehen ich
möchte jedenfalls einige minuten die
wenigen die ich habe jedenfalls auch
diese ursachen beschreibung um die
zusammenhänge nochmal verweisen jedes
zweite
körperverletzungsdelikt und jedes vierte
also jedes zweite
körperverletzungsdelikt geschieht unter
alkoholeinfluss jedes vierte
sexualdelikt unter alkoholeinfluss oder
drogeneinfluss wir haben wenn wir auf
alle tatverdächtigen gucken etwa elf
prozent der tatverdächtigen unter
alkohol einfluss etwa 6 prozent unter
drogeneinfluss und ich finde moment lang
sorgen durchaus mal überlegen wie unsere
drogenpolitik insgesamt so zusammenhängt
und wie die ursachenforschung an der
stelle aufgebaut ist ich bin jedenfalls
froh dass wir jetzt einen sachkundigen
drogenbeauftragten der bundesregierung
haben der diese fragen jetzt nochmal
sachkundige angeht das halte ich schon
für
ich will aber
ich gehe da wegen der kürze der zeit
noch ein weiteres fass aufmachen auch
wenn es sich etwas paradox anhört denn
all die debatten die wir jetzt gerade
geführt haben drehen sich nur um stoff
gebundene süchte es gibt aber veritabler
aufsetzen dazu die schon viele jahre als
sind die sich mit der frage des
glücksspiels auseinander setzen und
sagen eigentlich gehört genau diese
sucht auch noch in den paragraphen 64
hinein das heißt das wahre und echte
problem wenn wir auch zusammenhänge von
süchten und straftaten ist in wahrheit
noch viel größer als wir es gerade
gesprochen haben und an der stelle es
tut mir schrecklich leid auch wenn sie
sich das wünschen kann ich ebenso ganz
parteipolitik dann doch nicht ersparen
weil wenn wir uns gucken wie die
parteien so unterschiedlich mit genau
dieser frage des glücksspiels umgehen
dann gibt es eben tagesaktuelle
diskussionen die da echt mir zu tun
haben die union in nordrhein westfalen
hat sich überlegt abstandsflächen
zwischen spielhallen von 250 auf 100
meter zu reduzieren das heißt alle leute
in nordrhein westfalen dürfen sich jetzt
also durch die union in nordrhein
westfalen über mehr spielhallen freuen
und die presse aktuell sagt und das ist
eben der große unterschied bremen den
ganz anderen weg von 250 auf 500 meter
wird dort erhöht und den problematischen
stadtbad ihnen sagt der bremer
innensenator werden die möglicherweise
ganz verband aus diesen bereichen also
ich finde das sind doch mal herzhafte
diskussionen diese führten und so
indirekt mit diesen fragen zu tun haben
bitte entstehung also mit den
zusammenhängen von süchten auf der einen
seite und eben nicht nur stoff gebunden
denn die glücksspiel süchte sind die
teuersten sind es gibt keine teurere
sucht als glücksspiel kaum jemand der
spiel abhängig ist kann sich aus legalen
einkünften tatsächlich diese sucht
erlauben deswegen hängt es unmittelbar
mit begleit und beschaffungskriminalität
zusammen also tun sie uns einen gefallen
wenn wir das diskutieren dann bitte auch
über die ursachen diskutieren dann hat
es ein bisschen 'schon auch damit zu tun
welche partei das sagen danke
der gesetzentwurf wird jetzt also an die
entsprechenden ausschüsse überwiesen und
wir kommen damit dann noch einmal zum
thema mali bzw das engagement der
deutschen bundeswehr in mali die
abgeordneten haben ja schon einmal heute
darüber diskutiert da noch mit fokus auf
die blaue blauhelm mission minustah und
nun soll es um die fortsetzung
des der bundeswehr bei der mission der
europäischen union gehen im sahel
utm mali heißt die allerdings soll diese
mission klar verändert werden
dass die bundeswehr soll nicht mehr in
mali ausbilden sondern soll jetzt im
nachbarland niger ihren schwerpunkt
haben direkt immer die soll nur noch
eine minimale präsenz sein so schreibt
die bundesregierung in ihrem antrag denn
im land hat sich die lage auch für die
zusammenarbeit mit den dort vorhandenen
staaten verschlechtert seit august 2020
hat sich das militär zwei mal an die
macht geputscht
es gibt konflikte mit der militär
herunter außerdem sollen söldner der
kreml in seiner gruppe wagner mit dem
malischen militär kooperieren dazu
spricht jetzt verteidigungsministerin
lambrecht
rund 16.000 soldaten aus mali hat die
bundeswehr bisher ausgebildet es sollten
16.000 hoffnungsträger sein
16.000 soldaten die in zukunft selbst
für die sicherheit und stabilität in
ihrem land sorgen können und unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten nahmen genau
für diese aufgabe viel viel auf sich sie
schulten pioniere und infanteristen
vermittelten das nötige handwerkszeug
und grundkenntnisse des humanitären
völkerrechts und das alles in einem
gefährlichen umfeld und weit weg von
freunden und familien unsere truppe
erfüllt ihren auftrag hier professionell
und hoch motiviert und ich sagte ihnen
sie verdient dafür respekt und
anerkennung vielen dank für diesen
einsatz
das ist die positive seite zur wahrheit
gehören aber auch die schattenseiten der
zusammenarbeit mit den malischen macht
habe das manische regime sagt zwar dass
unsere hilfe bekommen sei aber seine
taten sprechen eine ganz andere sprache
seit monaten fordert die internationale
gemeinschaft baldige demokratische
wahlen ohne erfolg und wir sind
schockiert vom schrecklichen massaker in
muhr und die malischen streitkräfte
stehen in verdacht an diesen
menschenrechtsverletzungen und beteiligt
gewesen zu sein und noch nicht einmal
eine beweissicherung durch die vereinten
nationen wird von den malischen
machthabern möglich gemacht das ist ein
absolutes unding hier auch so zu
reagieren meine damen
und thematischen machthaber erklären
ganz offen dass sie mit russischen
kräften zusammenarbeiten und deshalb
sage ich ganz klar an dieser stelle
deshalb darf es kein weiter so bei
diesem mandat geben wir können nicht
vertreten das von uns ausgebildete
militärs später an der seite von
russischen kräften russisch und söldnern
eingesetzt werden und möglicherweise
menschenrechtsverletzungen begehen das
darf es nicht geben das können wir weder
gegenüber der zivilbevölkerung in mali
noch gegenüber unserer eigenen truppe
und auch nicht gegenüber der deutschen
bevölkerung verantworten und deshalb
wird es keine weitere ausbildung mehr in
mali geben und deshalb leben wir ihnen
dieses veränderte mandat auch vor die
obergrenze wird deutlich reduziert von
600 auf jetzt 300 soldatinnen und
soldaten
bei diesen umständen darf es kein weiter
so geben
ein schwerpunkt wird sie jetzt
vielleicht fragen wieso sind denn
weiterhin noch 300 soldaten vorgesehen
das ist ganz einfach zu beantworten denn
der schwerpunkt unseres engagement
künftig in dir aus zwei gründen erstens
und darüber haben das schon debattiert
aber für diejenigen die es noch nicht
verfolgt haben zwei argumente der saal
hat weiterhin für uns eine große
bedeutung und wir müssen unsere ziele
weiterverfolgen stabilität und
sicherheit in der region
und zweitens und hier genau liegt der
unterschied zumal die die regierung in
die er ist ein verlässlicher partner
denn sie hat ganz klar in den gesprächen
deutlich gemacht eine zusammenarbeit mit
söldnern eine zusammenarbeit mit
russischen kräften kommt für sie nicht
in frage das wollen sie ihrer
bevölkerung nicht zuzumuten weil sie die
gefahr von menschenrechtsverletzungen
genau sehen und das ist der unterschied
und deswegen werden wir auch uns weiter
englisch er engagiert meine damen und
herren dort bilden unsere soldatinnen
und soldaten spezial da aus und zwar mit
der operation gazelle und dieses
operation diese operation ist ein echtes
vorzeigeprojekt und davon konnte ich und
meine begleitung mir bei der sache reise
im april ein eigenes bild machen und ich
war sehr sehr beeindruckt und genau hier
wollen wir an unseren planungen fest
machen und die ausbildung bis dezember
zu ende führen und ja vorhin in der
debatte herunter von ihnen gehört
völlige überraschung dass wir das jetzt
bis zum ende dezember beenden wollen das
war schon immer so angelegt in diesem
mandat das war schon immer vorgesehen
und es ist gut genau weil es erfolgreich
ist weil die malischen soldaten jetzt
selbst in der lage sind ihre
spezialkräfte auszubilden das haben wir
ja genau in den gesprächen auch gehört
sie waren dabei das ist nachhaltig das
war der richtige ansatz und das gibt
auch dem einsatz unserer soldatinnen und
soldaten einen sinn meine damen und
herren wenn bei uns im sattel engagieren
dann verfolgen hier ganz klar andere
ziele als in russland als russland oder
auch china die ihre wirtschaftlichen und
militärischen aktivitäten in afrika
ausweiten uns geht es nicht darum
machtansprüche durchzusetzen und unseren
einfluss auszuweiten uns geht es darum
den kampf gegen den terrorismus mit zu
unterstützen wir wollen die staaten in
der region dabei unterstützen
selbstständiger zu werden und der
knüpfen unser engagement an unsere werte
und genau deshalb ist es wichtig im
sahel in dieser wichtigen rückführung zu
bleiben für die stabilität in
zentralafrika und für die sicherheit
auch hier in deutschland und europa mit
dem dessert haben wir einen partner in
der region auf den wir uns verlassen
können und der sich auf uns verlässt und
deswegen darf es auf der einen seite
kein weiter so geben keine weitere
ausbildung mehr in mali aber unser
engagement im die share weiterführen so
wie vorgesehen und deswegen bitte ich um
zustimmung zu diesem mandat
so hat verteidigungsministerin christine
lambrecht bis zum 31 mai 2023 möchte die
bundesregierung das mandat verlängern
nächste rednerin ist katja leikert aus
der unionsfraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wir debattieren heute zum zweiten mal
über mali die debatte die wir vor einer
stunde hier im hohen haus über das -
mandat geführt haben hat bereits 1
deutlich gemacht die bundesregierung
muss sich wirklich fragen lassen wie sie
sich das vorstellt hier mit wichtigen
mandaten es kann einfach nicht sein dass
wir die anträge zu - ma und eu tm erst
heute mittag erhalten haben beide
anträge kam um halb zwei gerade hatten
ein paar stunden hier vor der debatte
bei so einem ernsten und komplexen thema
sollte man mindestens mal ein paar tage
vorlauf haben stattdessen bekommen wir
den antrag auf den letzten drücker das
ist einfach unseriös
und keiner wird bestreiten wollen dass
wir im magie wirkt sich vor allem
schwierigen dilemma stehen es gibt
natürlich keine einfachen und schnellen
antworten unserer französischen partner
wurden aus mali rausgedrängt und das
wirft natürlich allerlei fragen
aus aufwies mit unserem beitrag in der
region weiter geht aber das liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ist nicht erst
vor drei tagen passiert sondern vor drei
monaten und trotzdem wir das mandat hier
kurz vor knapp durchgepeitscht nächste
woche soll bereits die abstimmung sein
und wer cdu/csu kann hier wirklich nur
dringlich dazu auffordern dass die
bundesregierung dem bundestag in zukunft
bei solch wichtigen fragen dem vom
anstand gebotenen vorlauf einräumt und
warum ist dieses man dazu wichtig
natürlich geht es um stabilität und
sicherheit in mali aber es geht eben
nicht nur um molly es geht um die
ausbildung und die herstellung von
sicherheit in der gesamten region es
geht vor allem auch natürlich um lisa
das haben sie eben deutlich gemacht und
burkina faso mauretanien und andere
länder wir als deutsche und europäer
haben selbstverständlich ein immenses
interesse daran dass sich die lage dort
zum besseren entwickelt und darum und
das muss man natürlich ehrlich sagen
steht es gerade nicht gut wir beobachten
ja schon länger was in mali passiert
mindestens seit herbst arbeitet mali eng
zusammen mit der russischen seltener
firma wagner dass eine firma die nichts
anderes ist als der verlängerte arm des
kremls und genau das müssen wir doch neu
bewerten und da müssen doch zu recht
alle alarmglocken angehen und um das
noch mal deutlich zu machen wir alle
waren geschockt von den bildern aus ihr
pin und butscher wo russische truppen
schlimmste verbrechen begehen morgen
vergewaltigen entführen und genau dort
sagen wir dass das konsequenzen haben
muss und diese haltung ist ja richtig
aber sie darf natürlich nicht nur für
die ukraine gelten sondern auch für mali
denn vor wenigen wochen konnten wir alle
lesen was in mora einer kleinstadt in
zentral mali vorgefallen ist hunderte
zivilisten wurden hier grausamste
massakriert und die täter das waren
malische regierungstruppen und russische
sollten das waren malische truppen man
muss es hier so aussprechen die von
deutschen offizieren in guter absicht
ausgebildet wurden und die nun mit
russischen truppen morden und das liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ist abscheulich
und das können wir natürlich niemals
akzeptieren
und trotzdem
kolleginnen kollegen müssen wir einen
weg finden wie wir in der region präsent
bleiben wie wir auf eine sinnvolle art
und weise die auch moralisch vertretbar
ist dort bleiben wir dürfen uns ja gar
keine illusionen machen wenn wir ein
vakuum hinterlassen werden russland und
die dschihadisten sich sputen ist zu
füllen und genau das ist der punkt warum
wir hier so sorgsam abwägen und beraten
müssen und wir von der cdu csu fraktion
leisten hierzu sehr sehr gerne unseren
beitrag für eine sache orientierte
debatte aber die regierung muss uns das
auch wirklich frau lamprecht in einem
angemessenen rahmen ermöglichen und
genau das ist unser eindringlicher
appell an sie heute hier herzlichen dank
katja rijkaard schließt ihre rede mit
anderen appell auf sie folgt nun katja
keul sie ist staatsministerin im
auswärtigen amt der
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wenn es um die militär mandate
in mali und in der region geht lohnt es
sich immer wieder mal einen blick zurück
zu werfen um zu verstehen warum die
bundeswehr seit nunmehr über zehn jahren
dort ist im jahr 2012 kollabierte erst
die malische armee und dann die malische
regierung die aus libyen mit den waffen
gaddafis zurückkehrenden touareg
verbündeten sich vorübergehend mit den
islamisten und besetzten den ganzen
norden des landes die schwache malische
armee ohne jede ausrüstung oder ernst zu
nehmenden sollt konnte dem nichts
entgegensetzen ein knappes jahr litten
die menschen unter einem grauenvollen
scharia regime
2013 wurde die einnahme der hauptstadt
bamako und die implosion des gesamten
staates die damalige situation war für
die menschen in mali die reinste hölle
ein failed state als freiraum für
islamistischen terror wäre auch für die
ganze region und letztlich auch für
europa ein nicht hinnehmbares
sicherheitsrisiko gewesen
und es war daher richtig den vormarsch
der islamisten militärisch zu stoppen
die un brachten daraufhin - mal auf den
weg und die eu beschloss malische
streitkräfte so auszubilden dass sie
künftig ihr land selber verteidigen
könnten rtm aber auch die zivilen
mission icap sahel mali und niger haben
mühsame militärische und zivile
aufbauarbeit bei der ausbildung von
sicherheitskräften geleistet mit
etlichen rückschlägen und ja auch mit
problemen aber auch mit substanziellen
erfolgen wie beispielsweise in niger was
aber nicht gelang war eine politische
stabilisierung und die umsetzung einer
guten regierungsführung in mali die
menschen hatten letztlich die korrupten
eliten wieder mal endgültig satt und
unterstützten 2020 und 2021 den erneuten
putsch durch das militär wir können aber
keine sicherheitskräfte für eine armee
ausbilden die ständig die macht selber
an sich reißt
es gibt noch immer keinen klaren
fahrplan für die rückkehr zur demokratie
selbst die harten sanktionen von ecowas
haben daran nichts geändert und die
verstärkte zusammenarbeit der malischen
regierung mit russischen truppen ist
ebenso wenig hinnehmbar wie die
ständigen menschenrechtsverletzungen ein
weiter so kann und wird es in mali
deshalb nicht geben
das habe ich auch bei meinen gesprächen
anfang februar in bamako deutlich
gemacht und auch die außenministerin hat
gerade erst gegenüber präsident wolter
und außenminister job eine rückkehr zur
demokratie und verfassung eingefordert
damit keinerlei fortschritte zu erkennen
sind haben wir auf eu-ebene anfang april
gemeinsam beschlossen die ausbildung der
malischen streitkräfte einzustellen auch
die bundeswehr wird deshalb bis auf
weiteres keine malischen soldatinnen und
soldaten mehr ausbilden was man wartet
dass wir ihn hier heute vorlegen ist
somit grundlegend geändert erstens in
bamako selbst werden nur noch bis zu 15
soldatinnen und soldaten im das
missionshaus quartiers verbleiben sie
werden nur noch auf strategischer ebene
beraten und unsere vernetzung vor ort
sicherstellen das ist wichtig damit wir
einen direkten zugang zu den malischen
ansprechpartnern behalten und es ist
eine frage der transparenz das auch im
mandat klar zu verankern
klar ist außerdem eine wiederaufnahme
durch die hintertür wird es nicht geben
sollten sich die verhältnisse wieder
verändern wäre eine wiederaufnahme der
ausbildung nur mit erneuter zustimmung
des bundestages möglich
zweitens haben wir den tschad auf dem
einsatzgebiet der bundeswehr gestrichen
die eu plant ohnehin kein
ausbildungsmaßnahmen im tschad wo es in
den letzten jahren nicht einmal den
ansatz einer demokratischen entwicklung
gegeben hat und deshalb ist das auch nur
folgerichtig den tschad auch formal auf
dem mandat herauszunehmen das gilt
übrigens auch für das eu mandat für eine
entsprechende änderung werden wir uns in
brüssel einsetzen
die ausbildung der spezialkräfte in
niger hingegen werden wir mit bis zu 230
soldatinnen und soldaten unverändert
fortsetzen und bis jahresende
voraussichtlich erfolgreich abschließen
die bisherige zwischen bilanz ist
positiv
auch im anschluss an diese ausbildung
will er weiter mit uns zusammenarbeiten
und wir sind dazu grundsätzlich auch
bereit dieser ursprünglich bilaterale
deutsche spezialkräfte einsatz gab fälle
ist teil von atm perspektive tm also
eher zu einem heute im sahel werden
müssen
insgesamt halbiert sich die
mandatsobergrenze durch die einstellung
der militärischen ausbildung in mali von
600 auf 300
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
ministerin sagte eben noch zu - die
mandats entscheidung ist noch
schwieriger als vor einem jahr das gilt
umso mehr für die ausbildungsmission mit
den notwendigen existenz existenziellen
veränderungen an diesem mandat setzen
wir aber wichtige botschaften wir haben
klare rote linien beim einsatz unserer
soldatinnen und soldaten
wir geben ihnen keinen auftrag den sie
mit ihren mitteln nicht erfüllen können
weil die voraussetzungen nicht gegeben
sind
gleichzeitig zeigen wir in nidda dass
wir trotz des krieges in europa dieser
region nicht aus dem blick verlieren
werden wir ziehen uns nicht einfach
zurück und überlassen anderen das feld
das ist eine frage der verantwortung für
die sicherheit und zukunftschancen der
menschen im saal helfen und für unsere
sicherheit in europa vielen dank
soweit die staatsministerin im
auswärtigen amt katja keul ist hier noch
einmal darauf eingegangen bis zu 300
soldatinnen und soldaten sollen bei
diesem 1 satz 1 gesetzt werden und die
springer von der fdp-fraktion hat auch
eine zeit lang als zeitsoldat gearbeitet
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren verehrte gäste wir
debattieren hier den antrag der
bundesregierung das engagement der
bundeswehr in der sahelzone insbesondere
mali und niger zu verlängern wir sind
seit 2013 in der region militärisch
aktiv 5000 soldaten haben seither in
diesem einsatz dort bedient insgesamt
hat das deutsche engagement den
steuerzahler vier milliarden euro
gekostet und die katastrophale bilanz
wurde er im grunde auch eindrucksvoll
vorgetragen ein rohrkrepierer
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
die bundesregierung sagt in ihrer
zielsetzung für den einsatz es ging um
frieden stabilität und sicherheit
nun muss die bundesregierung zugeben
dass es heute mehr islamistischen
widerstandsgruppen gibt in der region
als vor zwölf jahren und sie muss
zugeben dass es einen deutlichen anstieg
der zahl der anschläge gibt und auch der
menschenrechtsverletzungen die gerade
erwähnt wurden die bundesregierung hat
als ziel angegeben
wohlstand zu vergrößern und perspektive
für afrikas jugend zu schaffen
fakt ist nach angaben der vereinten
nationen dass die anzahl der menschen
die auf humanitäre hilfe angewiesen sind
seit 2008 zehn von 4,1 mio millionen auf
6,3 millionen angestiegen ist das ist in
vier jahren ein anstieg von 50 prozent
und
die bundesregierung hat immer wert
darauf gelegt dass es dort
rechtsstaatlich zugeht und demokratisch
und erwähnt wurde er schon der berühmte
putsch im jahr 2020 im august die
bundesregierung aber nicht sonderlich
beeindruckt hat den einsatz dort nicht
verändert nicht abgebrochen einfach
weitergemacht und jetzt stellt sie sich
hierhin beklagt die festigung einer
militärregierung und ausgefallene
demokratische wahlen was für eine
heuchelei wenn man jahrelang die
soldaten ausgebildet hat die für eine
stabilisierung dieser militärregierung
jetzt ihren beitrag leisten
das kommt ja noch viel schlimmer der
chef der militärregierung ist in den
jahren 2008 und 2016 in deutschland bei
der bundeswehr ausgebildet worden sie
selbst tragen die verantwortung für die
katastrophale entwicklung in mali und
das muss hier auch so deutlich
ausgesprochen werden
der einsatz der bundeswehr in mali ist
nach allen kriterien die die bundes die
bundesregierung selber definiert hat
gescheitert
aber die frage ist ob es dort überhaupt
um frieden menschenrechte wohlstand und
demokratie gehen ich möchte mal ehe und
bei den spd-politiker zitieren immer
gesagt hat in der internationalen
politik geht es nie um demokratie oder
menschenrechte es geht um die interessen
von staaten unter scheint auch hier der
fall zu sein die bundesregierung lässt
in ihrem antrag hier im grunde auch die
hose runter jedenfalls zur hälfte sie
verlegt den schwerpunkt der deutschen
beteiligung von mali in den nachbarstaat
niger
niger nach zahlen der vereinten nationen
das am wenigsten entwickelte land der
welt und zugleich ist es doch reich ist
ziemlich reich an uran
es ist ja die sechs größte uran fördern
nation der welt seit 1971 wird das uran
vorkommen in niger von französischen
staatskonzern ausgebeutet derzeit bei
aktuell importiert frankreich ein
viertel des ihres urahns aus nieder um
den durst und den hunger der heimischen
atomkraftwerke zu stellen aber dieser
uranabbau der hat eben auch seine folgen
denn die abbaugebiete überziehen das
land der tuareg fast vollständig und
erzeugen dort widerstand es kommt zu
massiver umweltverschmutzung zu
krankheiten zu verstrahlten
brunnenwasser und vor allem auch zu
austrocknung 'nen und ausführungen und
wenn frau berbalk sich zuschalten lässt
aus nieder und sagt es liege an der
kläger an der klimakrise dann sagt sie
nur die halbe wahrheit die andere
wahrheit ist nämlich dass das fossile
grundwasser benötigt wird für den
uranabbau das alles sind die fakten wir
haben uns zur zum handlanger situation
schulung sicht weile mich wir haben uns
hier die bundesregierung hat deutschland
zum handlanger französischer interessen
in der sahel zone gemacht dass es keine
werte bereitete außenpolitik dass es
dumm außenpolitik wir wollen
außenpolitik im deutschen interesse und
deswegen lehnen sie diesen einsatz punkt
ich bedanke mich für die aufmerksamkeit
der springer war das als der afg
fraktion zum bundeswehr einsatz in mali
zu der europäischen
ausbildungsmission und nächster redner
ist ulrich schlechte der außenpolitische
sprecher der fdp fraktion
[Musik]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen nach dieser
eindrucksvollen rede für af dtv wollen
wir jetzt bitte wieder zu den fakten
dieses mandates zurückkehren und mit den
dingen auseinandersetzen die uns
eigentlich alle bewegen sollten denn
seit 2013 hat der deutsche bundestag
jährlich die beteiligung der bundeswehr
an der mission der vereinten nationen -
ma und der mission der europäischen
union
beschlossen seit 2003 10 konnten wir uns
auch schon über viele positive
auswirkungen unseres engagement freuen
so konnten wir den islamistischen terror
im norden malis eine zeitlang
zumindestens bekämpfen und begrenzen und
das war auch das ursprungs motiv dass
wir dort vor ort eingegriffen haben in
letzter zeit mehren sich natürlich die
negativen meldungen aus der region aber
die menschen vor ort vertrauen nach wie
vor auf unsere hilfe und auf unseren
beistand und dabei rede ich explizit von
der zivilbevölkerung die schweren
schweren schweren sorgen entgegen sehen
und wenn man das beispiel zum beispiel
darum nimmt robert bei - mal gesprochen
haben dort sind in den letzten monaten
ist die bevölkerungszahl von 90 auf 120
tausend menschen
angewachsen weil diese 30.000 menschen
die nah gekommen sind die sicherheit
unserer truppen vor 10 gegenüber den
islamisten die um sie herum ihnen die
probleme bereiten nach dem militärputsch
in mali im august 2020 und
verschlechtert sich zunehmend die
sicherheitslage in mali im april 20 21
gab es auch noch diesen putsch im tschad
und zuletzt wurde im januar 2022 in
burkina faso
zwischen diesen ländern liegt der nische
der sich zuletzt als der
stabilitätsanker in der region erwiesen
hat und dem wir deswegen unbedingt
weiter unterstützen müssen es ist daher
folgerichtig dass wir den schwerpunkt
unseres engagements im rahmen der tm
ausbildungsmission nun von mali nach wie
sehr verlegen soweit also die debatte
hier im deutschen bundestag zum
bundeswehr einsatz in mali die wir für
das erste verlassen ich kann ihnen aber
sagen dass diese dieses thema noch
einmal ins plenum kommen wird das hier
ist nämlich erst die erste debatte also
von daher wird uns das thema noch
beschäftigen und wir wollen ja auch die
zeit nutzen sie sollten noch über andere
geschehnisse und nachrichten zu
informieren morgen sind wir ab 8.45 hier
wieder aus dem deutschen bundestag für
sie dabei und jetzt geht es aber erst
einmal weiter mit meinen kollegen von
der tat
aktuell engagiert meinungsstark impulse
für die europäische eingestreut um
mieten explosion oder gegners darf
weiter gerätselt werden aus der wir sind
ganz wichtig was dabei herauskommt die
phoenix runde heute um 22 15 mit diesem
thema
[Musik]